Hey fuckers,
I'm tweeting at the same time.
Here we go.
I wonder if Goldberg assuming for that.
That's a shit,
right?
Yeah.
Oh,
we shouldn't probably shouldn't
start every podcast going.
Here we go.
We got a few sound issues folks.
So it took us some time.
We got it together though.
Um,
this episode of the Joe Rogan experience
podcast is brought to you by ting.
Uh,
I've met several people
now who've switched over to
Tang ever since we started
doing this in the podcast and uh,
all of them have been happy.
And then they're also that
they definitely saved money.
Um,
also,
uh,
date they get a great service.
If you don't know what tango is,
10 is the cell phone service
that uses a sprint backbone,
but they don't do it with
all the other shenanigans.
Like most cell phone companies have,
like they use the network
of a major company,
but the way they have it set up as a,
you can cancel anytime you want.
Look what they just added it
to the website coming soon.
Apple iPhone.
Oh Wow.
Look at that sign.
You could sign up right now if you go
to [inaudible] dot com slash devices uh
Huh.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's bad ass.
That's great.
I'm good then.
I'm glad they,
uh,
they did that.
Most sprint carries out now,
right?
Yeah.
Joey just switch Joey.
That's right.
I'm so,
I have you talked to him about it?
I wonder if he'd like,
he loves it.
It's like a,
you know,
it's music too.
He doesn't have to have a,
um,
uh,
an iPod anymore.
All these phones do that now,
man.
These,
uh,
the new cell phones today are
like mini computers and uh,
never is that more true than the,
um,
nevers that more true than
the Samsung Galaxy s three.
And the note,
those things are giant.
This note thing is this
mega fucking phone.
It's amazing.
And it does everything
you get online with it.
You can record voice memos with it.
You can,
you know,
download apps.
It used to be that if you were going
to get a Google phone over an iPhone,
you were fucked.
But now if you're into a big
screen because the Google phone,
so it really,
the only way to go if you want to have
one phone that does everything that you
can watch movies or watch a movie on
an iPhone is a not quite as pleasurable
experience,
you know.
But watching the one on one
of those notes that's legit,
like about big enough,
you know,
I take it to the next level.
I watched,
uh,
the new funny or die movie I Steve,
which is a ridiculous movie about Steve
Jobs because they just wanted to make
the first Steve jobs movie and it's so,
Riddick has Justin Long place Steve
Jobs who was also in the commercials for
apple growing up as the,
you know,
the Geek and the stuff anyways,
but they,
they only have it online.
You can't watch it anywhere.
So you could just stream it
though using an apple TV.
Have you done that yet?
Where you're just on your iPhone,
you're like,
oh,
I want to watch this movie.
You just send it to your TV.
Yes.
That's so great.
That's the best thing.
I wasn't caught air share
or whatever the fuck.
Yeah.
I don't know what it's called.
That is pretty bad ass.
Yeah,
it's a pretty amazing idea.
Really.
Right.
You've put photos on your
television with Apple TV.
It's amazing.
I love it.
Yeah.
I'm a,
I'm,
well,
I just,
I'm a big fan of technology as you are.
It's just so cool when new shit comes out.
Like Dunkin Trust was
telling me about oculus rift.
This is virtual reality
shit they're working on now.
Yeah.
We're supposed to have him on a podcast.
Oh my goodness,
dude.
They have a,
a one where the m and Omni
Directional treadmill.
So the treadmill goes in any
direction and you're running,
I'll talk about this on the plane.
Okay.
How have we talked about,
see the video?
We watched a video,
the military,
uh,
talk about on Nearpod.
No,
you're probably guys we did a long time
ago and that's why it's weird because I
was listening to old podcasts of me
and you and there's so many things that
we've talked about that I thought,
like we've talked about recently.
I was like,
wait,
I've never heard this before.
We are stoners,
dude.
What do you mean repeat story?
There's no way around it.
No,
I know.
But like,
this is a perfect example.
I was like,
I,
I've,
I've seen this weight.
I've seen it.
Oh wait,
we did this like a long time ago.
Well,
we do so much.
Isn't it ridiculous?
I don't want to fucking podcast.
We've done 351 podcast now.
Yeah,
that's a lot of Goddamn podcasts.
Himes three hour,
same stories over and over again.
My brain is not sharp enough
to not do that at the trial.
We can't remember.
I think we're way better at it now.
We're way better at it
now than we used to be.
Right.
You know,
I used to tell the same goddamn
story every three weeks.
Uh,
rogan.ting.com save 25 bucks off of
either cell phone service or one of their
bad ass android phones.
Uh,
another one of the cool things about ting
is that they give you credit on unused
service.
This is like my favorite thing
that I've ever heard a company do.
You use less than you thought you would.
Tin Drops you down to the next
level and a credit to you.
The difference on your next bill.
It's amazing.
Yeah,
that's,
that's beautiful.
They,
yeah,
they charge you for what you use.
And if you don't use
as much as you thought,
they hook you up.
It's really a how every
company should work.
You could this like this idea that
companies have to like squeeze the last
dollar out of you that they have to lock
you up and contracts and if you leave
the contract costs you
hundreds of dollars.
That's some creepy shit,
man.
It's creepy.
Oh,
but in two years you'll be
eligible for a new phone.
Are you ready?
And they just suck into
the little hole thing.
Doesn't do that.
Go to rogan.ting.com
save yourself some cash
and they're thinking that's
just really cool to uh,
they don't have any limits on bandwidth.
They don't throttle your bandwidth.
So like if you are a heavy
user and you're on a plan,
you know exactly how much it will cost.
There's no overage cause like a
lot of companies will go like,
oh you went over your amount,
we're charging an extra amount
and then it's this per minute.
You're not,
you're getting the same amount.
You know what it's that you know
of that you signed up for it.
Right?
Like you're not getting any extra fees
and if you want to use a shitload of,
you know,
if you want to spend a lot of
money and use as much data,
none to man,
you could if you wanted to and they
wouldn't throttle it or stop it.
Isn't it interesting
that uh,
that bandwidth still can
be expensive in the world?
A phones,
like we've totally licked that
shit on the regular Internet,
right?
Like you just get mad bandwidth,
man.
You know,
you could get mad bandwidth at home,
but on your phone like,
oh bitch man,
we got to ration this shit.
Kind of like AOL.
Remember if you went
over your minutes on AOL,
you only had like 400 minutes and if you
went over it with a shit load of money,
I don't remember that at all.
All she went over the minutes.
It would cost you
money.
Yeah.
You had to sit there and look at the clock
the whole time you're on the internet
like it's a fucking
bomb about to blow off.
Fuck up.
What did they fuck up?
They were on top of the world.
What monkey over there?
I've dropped the ball.
All could.
If they adapted and
grew with the Internet,
they could have been Facebook.
Yeah.
We should have been Facebook.
They were the original Facebook.
Aol was the original Facebook.
People would like I am.
People know my space.
Yeah,
well no.
It was more like,
yeah,
I guess Facebook is more
like people's friends,
but it was,
it's actually,
it would say even different
because there was been,
there had been nothing like it before.
Right.
Nothing like it exists.
I got laid off AOL many times,
son of a bitch or a member directory
searches within 15 miles of my location.
You know,
you put it in your address shows who's
online and then you could use to just be
able to chat with those people.
Like there's 20 people online
that live five miles near me.
I can tell you go through
their profiles like,
Oh dude,
dude,
oh chick.
You just like,
Oh hey,
what are you doing?
I actually got laid that way.
I found a girl that lived like
three streets down from me.
I bet you were one of the first thousand
people ever to get laid from AOL.
I probably,
that was like really early.
It was right when,
uh,
what year are we talking about it?
I would say 98.
97.
It was right up.
It's when they first invented
like the instant messaging.
It was not what,
they didn't invent it,
ICQ or whatever did,
but uh,
where you used to be able to instant
message people and would be an instant
message.
Instant message.
You've got mail,
you've got mail.
They dropped it.
They dropped that ball and Twitter
took over like a motherfucker.
Where's the AOL Guy Now?
He's probably sitting there going,
crying,
maybe made a kajillion dollars and
just gave up on the fucking thing.
I think it still works though,
because people still
have AOL email addresses.
Yeah,
I know dude.
It was an AOL email address.
I think I still do.
I think I just signed in the other day
on AOL instant messenger because I still
use it.
Well I used to use that.
Yeah.
And what was the other one in quake,
we used AOL instant messenger
and we used to use a ICQ.
That's right.
I see Q is a big one.
We had like a little quick clan names.
It was like who you signed in as us.
The ICQ number.
That was like a 20 digit
number that you have to remember
to remember the fucking number.
What's your ICQ number?
Yeah,
you'd have it on a like a thing
that you could give out with people.
Like a program that you press it.
It gives up the IQ number.
I secure number here.
Yeah,
the old days folks.
Um,
stamps.com is another one of our podcasts.
Uh,
if you own a business and you
sell shit through the Internet,
you know what,
go into the post offices.
Like it's ridiculous.
It takes a lot of time.
We should do a stamps.com podcast.
What do you mean?
You just said stamps.com is
another one of our podcast.
Did I say it?
It's another one I would podcast sponsors.
I forgot the word,
but wait,
w we should do a podcast all about stamps,
about stamps.com all about stamps period.
Call it like a podcast challenge where
you have to do a podcast for three hours
about something that would suck.
Suck pranking stamps.com
employees or something like it.
What else do we do?
We get after like 15 minutes we'd be dry.
Liddy we will be like,
you know what,
there's no stamps.com and Africa
and Africa is fucking crazy,
right to hoot.
But you could have stamps.com in Africa.
You could cause it's all
based on your computer.
You print out your own postage.
So you could be in Africa,
in the tent,
print your own stamps out and give it to
a horse and tell him to send it to some
of these horses in Africa or they'd
just eat them when I get one.
Yeah,
I don't know.
They'd probably,
there probably is no animal.
It's egret.
Oh,
eat zebra.
Did you know that?
I did not know that people a zebra,
but apparently people actually
like the taste of zebra.
Well if you're like super hungry
you would eat any animal you saw.
Oh,
I'm sure you'd be like grabbing mice.
You'd be cats are fucked.
Yeah.
Would you'd eat everything
you'd eat my sud,
everything you could.
People that are in like those prisons,
those a Korean prison
camps that you hear about.
Like that's one of the things I say they
eat rats and they get sick because they
little eat a raw rat,
but they're so hungry.
They just have to eat.
They have to eat.
You didn't have bullies in your villages?
He just had kids at eight.
Yeah,
Dude.
Times times used to
suck hard but not today.
Today you got something like stamps.com
and your lazy ass can just sit there and
you computer and print up
all your bullshit and send
your stuff out and not have
to wait in line to get everything weighed.
They also include a,
if you click on the microphone in the
upper right hand corner of the website and
um,
enter in the code word j r e they give
you a special offer with a free digital
scale and a $55 in postage and coupons.
Uh,
it's really easy to use in
a few [inaudible] if you
buy any one of those death
squad dot.
T V t shirts that uh,
Brian Creates.
And I understand that cat
number three is on the way.
Yeah,
it was up till seven 30
this last night doing it.
I've tried to finish it out and try
to do the final design by this week.
Powerful cat number three.
Um,
so if you've,
if you've bought those before in the past,
then you have uh,
enjoyed how well stamps.com works.
It's fucking a beautiful thing
if you have your own business.
And uh,
if you look at it for something to do
like making a business and selling shit
online,
it's probably a pretty fucking
cool way to own your own business.
It really is.
Yeah.
If you think about if you actually
have a cool product to feel like,
especially if you're someone like an
artist or you're someone who knows how to
make something that people want to buy
and you can put your stuff for sale
online and then just sell it and
just do it all out of your house,
like your,
your house becomes your business.
I told Esther this like almost a year ago
because she was looking for ideas to make
money that she should just sit there,
draw like every hour,
just draw another drawing.
So each one of those drugs for $15 online,
you know,
just like sit there and just
make drawings or do something,
you know,
that's a shit wage.
That's like $15 an hour for,
well I wouldn't take an hour.
It's going to take out
like a good percent profit.
Well,
profit is going to get eaten up because
everything $15 how much does it cost to
get it going to cost to send it?
Well,
no,
you add shipping and
stuff like that to it.
Oh you asked?
Yeah.
You clever bastard and I think
you should be a business mogul.
I don't understand why you're not I,
yeah,
but like,
like,
and she did,
I think she did do a few drawings on set,
but like they're just
like what sites like Etsy,
s y or there's like
fiverr.com which is a website.
You can get anyone to do anything for $5.
It,
it's,
yeah,
it's just fuck fiber.
And it's actually one
of the best things ever.
Like,
like if you need something
real quick and you're like,
no,
I need a logo.
It's a cat pooping please.
$5 you know?
And then there was somebody
was so fun and yeah,
it's really cool.
But you know,
things like that you can sit there
and start a home business pretty easy.
Maybe not something that would pay for
everything at the start that at least
extra income coming in,
you know?
Yeah,
no,
I know what you mean.
It's really easy to do it.
And stamps.com gives you the ability to
just do it from your house so easy where
the fact that you can just print your
shipping and just put it in your mailbox
and good to go.
You don't have to leave your house ever.
That is a beautiful time saver and as
you've said if you use a Promo Code j r e
you will get this special offer and you
will also probably get a boner if you
can.
I predict it if you're capable of them.
If you're not,
don't worry about it.
It's overrated,
right party.
You better off just going fishing and
don't go to dig party in your mouth,
talk cop cause that's just rude.
Take potty mouth.com is my
website somehow or another.
This is a weird world.
We're also sponsored by on it.
If you go to o n n I t and
use the code name Rogan,
you will save yourself 10%
off any and all supplements.
If you haven't been there in awhile,
go there and check it out.
We got a lot of crazy new shit.
We started carrying a raw foods like
walnut and almond cashew butter.
Ooh,
yeah,
that sounds awesome.
It's dope and it's really good for you.
Um,
it's a,
it's delicious too,
man.
It's,
uh,
it's,
it's a trilogy butter and it's
just a really fucking healthy nuts.
Not like the ones that,
yeah,
no nut butters.
They're uh,
they're some of the more nutritious
and versatile foods on the planet.
I was thinking of,
of the website,
I was thinking black,
white,
and Asian.
I didn't know what
Asian nuts,
just like a teapot trilogy Darya.
What,
how much different people's loads
look from different countries.
Do you think there's like
countries that have like different,
like parts of the world,
like you think you,
like there's a person out
there who can analyze,
come again,
like that's when you know you're
a whore when like someone can,
you could taste come like a fine vintage,
you know,
like some,
some gals,
you know,
like in can taste wine,
like some people are really good.
Like my friend Matt,
my friend Matt is like a wine,
what are they?
Somali,
AA,
whatever they call them.
Super Connoisseur.
Yeah,
he has like a room in his house.
You can give him a glass of wine.
You could tell you what
kind of wine it is.
I wonder if it's a gal out there that
can tell you where the loads come for
sure.
She's like,
oh,
these are Mexican.
I know these are Mexican loans.
Definitely,
definitely South Africa.
She could narrow it down.
Portugal,
north somewhere in northern Europe
with a little bit of checklist,
a little wacky in it.
And there it gives it that nutty texture.
Um,
we also carry a,
besides food and nutritional supplements
carry a bunch of fitness equipment too.
Um,
we even carry BLENDTEC blenders.
Well we try to do on,
on it,
add on.
I mean you try to come up with
a name for what the company is.
It's,
it's basically like a
human performance website.
I mean that's what it's about.
Like the,
all the fitness equipment is all
stuff for functional strength.
All the,
uh,
why you show him the fucking ghost rider.
Well,
a lot of people have been talking about
how on it now sells ghost writers weapon
and Oh,
I don't have you seen that or not?
Ghost rider had like a chain,
didn't know he also had this
when the steel maces that uh,
there's been a lot of people online
showing that it's the exact same thing as
the coast writers.
Well what they are folks,
they're not weapons.
So there's way more effective
shit to use as a weapon.
I'm sure you've heard of guns.
Yeah.
And uh,
knives and swords and stuff like that.
Yeah,
those are better with this is,
it gives you,
it's a,
this is a steel mace and they give you
like weird functional strength because
it's oddly waited with a Macy's is a long,
long steel thick tube.
It's very thick,
so it's difficult to grab.
And then there's a ball
metal ball at the end of it.
And so when do you,
as you wield this around?
Like Karl gotch was a big
believer in the steel mason.
He was a very famous
catch wrestling guy in a,
uh,
a fitness guru.
He,
uh,
he would have these guys
get into tremendous shape
before he even allowed them
to take his,
uh,
his,
his wrestling classes.
He was like famous for it.
And this is one of the
things that he really loved,
but he had a huge one.
Man,
that guy was a psycho.
There's the clubs as well.
These things are not weapons style.
What they are is because they're weighted.
It's a,
it's a handle and then
the weight is all long,
you know,
and because it goes,
the longer the clubs are the,
the,
the weirder they are to wheeled around,
you know,
and it gives you this really interesting,
uh,
functional workout,
of like your whole body.
You could,
you could give you all,
it's all like swinging and catching and
controlling and it gives you a good,
with like a
lightweight,
like I use a 25 pounder in each arm.
It's,
it's amazing how,
how much of a workout you get with that.
It's really incredible.
It doesn't seem like that much weight,
ladies.
Good to sit on it and
compare their pussy depth.
Take a little chalk,
Joe,
please don't even try that at home
because if someone died from it,
that could
do,
can you imagine a girl up?
She could get all the way to the bottom.
Sure.
Imagine a girl would get one of
those mace balls in her mouth ball.
We said we should try this.
No.
We also sell a kettle burnmar.
Yes,
Amy Schumer and Ari Shaffir.
So either one of them was
a good candidate for us.
Uh,
we have weight vests.
Now we have,
um,
uh,
a great kettle bell DVD,
extreme kettlebell cardio workout,
which is so good.
It's almost impossible to keep in stock.
Keith Webb or the guy who makes it has
a real hard time keeping them in stock
because it's an incredible workout.
I do it with a 35 pound Kettle Bell
and it beats my Dick in the ground.
Um,
and the chimpanzee one is the,
is a 35 pounder.
We're going to have some other ones to
come to more of the primal bells anyway.
Use a code name,
Rogan,
and save yourself 10 to 10.
What do you laugh now?
Just the idea of you watching a DVD out
outside and you're just dry humping the
ground as hard as he can take it.
That's not what I meant.
This is an old cowboy expression.
Kick his dick into the dirt.
Yeah.
I just,
look,
what I really want to do is I really
want to get more fucking endurance so I
just,
I do pushups while I
tried to fuck the ground.
That's the move.
It's so fun.
Yeah.
You imagine if there was a class where
they taught you how to fuck harder?
No,
I'll tell you what it is.
I know this girl,
they just went to a yoga rave and that's
exactly what it was just a fuck fest.
It was just,
it was the closest thing to look
that looked like a futuristic cult.
They were doing like Dunkin
owns in it and stuff like that.
Like a home.
It was just as people all wearing neon
and having like glow sticks while doing
yoga and half the guys had like barely
any clothes on half the girls that barely
any clothes.
It was creepy looking.
They start fucking,
no,
but it just because it was so futuristic,
like they were oming through it
and like it was this big call,
a cm type thing.
Like it'd be one thing if they did
yoga and just fucked like wild animals.
Yeah.
I think it was borderline
getting to that though.
That's,
that's what the people that were there
and you just need goodness step in
plants.
Slowly bring desk squad
people to infiltrate their
organization for the outside.
Let you guys have a really good start.
It's an interesting idea.
We liked the idea but you're
not fucking each other.
Okay.
You guys are like 25 just
stretching out next to each other.
Come on.
How come nobody's talking to anybody?
Let's stop with the homes.
If we should do that to that podcast
festival in August or September,
like we're like,
I'm ready.
We're there and it's like all these
fans from all around the real,
from different fans of different podcasts.
We should just like make it like all
the death squad people like overtake it.
Like we just have a bunch of
crazy people mixed in with like,
Hey,
I just like tech podcasts.
What are you guys doing?
Well,
you know what we could do is we could
do our own desk squad podcast festival.
Yeah,
we could easily do that.
We can just take over this one.
Well I would we take over one
because we could be,
why would cause bird,
they're already no.
Well why would he not take over?
But we could like,
like they ha they let
them do all the planning.
Like oh they got a good rooms at hotels.
They got,
you know like they got that you
want to steal their business?
No,
no,
no.
I'm just saying like have all
of our fans go there and mob it.
You know what I mean?
Like it's like if you go to a lot of
Palooza and it was all nirvana fans,
you know what I mean?
It's impossible to do because
there's still going to be other fans.
Not If night,
if the majority is like 99.9% like
Joe Rogan and desk squad fans.
Well,
there's no way they would ever do that.
Yeah.
But Dude,
she always going to get
like all the other fans too.
I'll do it.
I have to do is just be in
line to buy tickets first.
Oh yeah.
You know what I mean?
Is it a fine to do it a
finite amount of tickets,
um,
to a point of being able
to stay at the hotel and,
and all that.
Yeah,
but don't you think that their reserve,
all those like people,
oh no,
I'm in advance.
No,
no.
I mean this is a small festival
is this is only our second,
their second year too.
I think that's bad Karma,
I'd think.
No,
no,
no.
It's giving him money.
But even sending our people in there,
no,
no.
I'm just saying any of them.
First of all,
to many of our people are crazy,
right.
But we,
we have live performances of a desk squad.
Kevin Pereira is pointless and if you
want to have a Joe Rogan one and there's a
comedy show the second night across
the street and this huge school,
it's going to be pretty cool.
It's going to be all of
these podcasts there.
We should just take over it
and that's what I'm saying.
Am I settled down?
You should just take over.
How about you stop being a
lazy bitch and we make our own.
Yeah,
they get that better.
There you go.
Deaf squad podcast festival.
That's a good idea.
That way we don't have to think about,
you guys fucking stole the,
the Lollapalooza of podcasts.
You guys.
Oh,
I came in and nothing
overwhelming your asshole friends.
That's true.
Mean if we had too many people.
Yeah.
Well we have to get the tickets out quip
cause those death quad dickheads by him
up.
Well show up and go.
We're still doing it since
September and if you want to do it,
I'd love to have you to do one to,
maybe we'll do a one of our
podcasts there and it depends on,
you know,
what my schedule looks like,
but it sounds like it'd be fun.
Yeah.
Is it,
they have good studios
and you bring laptops?
Oh yeah.
It's,
it's at a hotel and it's like a,
they have like three huge,
like kind of ballrooms or it usually
people get married and stuff in there and
having a life stages and stuff.
It's pretty cool.
How sweet.
Okay.
Fuckers on it.
Dot Com.
Code name Brogan.
Save yourself some money.
Um Oh,
in shows coming up.
Yes.
Brian.
Uh,
in,
uh Oh,
it's muffs had with Brian Carey.
I was so hot the other day
when we were doing a shotgun.
You remember her name?
I was like that check.
What's her name?
[inaudible] suck cause I like her.
She's very nice.
She's awesome.
She's very,
very nice person.
And she's got a podcast on the desk
squad podcast network as does our co,
our pal Kevin Pereira,
a great podcast.
Very funny guy.
Um,
the shows you got coming up are San
Francisco on Sunday and Friday and
Saturdays.
Sacramento.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it's a Friday and Saturday.
We have four shows at the
punchline in Sacramento.
It's me,
Sam Tripoli and Tony Hinchcliffe,
a fine show comedy show and comedy show.
And it's Sunday,
Cinco de Mile.
Uh,
we're going to be in San
Francisco at the cops,
which is a pretty intimidating
get out of Sacramento for Cinco de Mayo.
An excellent movie.
Right.
Exactly.
Nothing wrong with some
happy drunk Mexicans,
white people that are scarier.
Yeah.
Oh,
you go to [inaudible] dot TV.
All the links for it tickets
or a Dick's party in my mouth.
Why you?
Why you worried about Sunday?
Why are you worried about Sunday?
Huh?
I'm not worried about Sunday.
He said it's intimidating.
The club is so huge there.
I remember going there with you and
that there was like double layers.
It's,
and it's just goes back forever.
That's so scary.
Scary.
No,
I mean to try to be like,
you know that it's a
filling.
It is is,
it's,
it's tricky for sure.
But the other thing that's weird about
those big shows is comms used to be the
old cobb's was the most intimate club in
the country and it was the smallest cub
club that I worked because it was so cool.
Like it was only,
I think a hundred people,
like maybe at the most
they did like 150 people.
It was really small and I did it a few
times and you're just in there with them.
There's everyone's packed in together.
You see each other,
you could smell each other,
you know,
and it was just so,
so perfect.
A comedy club.
It wasn't a tiny,
tiny stage.
Like a lot of New York clubs is
a lot of small clubs in New York.
And uh,
one of the issues with New York
is space and some of the clubs,
the stage is so small,
you're literally standing closer
to the audience than I am to you.
Right?
Like you'll,
you'll be standing on
the table like literally,
and it's just too close to people.
Like you don't have any room to move.
And so you know,
is,
that's fine if you're
one of those up upright,
standard monologists it just stands
there and doesn't do anything.
But if you want to do
anything physical on stage,
there's literally no room to do it.
Right?
Yeah.
I,
there was one like that in Pittsburgh
where it was like a sports bar where
you're basically sitting on this huge
stage in the middle of this room,
like a s like a square.
And it was just small enough where you
felt like you would accidentally fall off
at any time.
And then there was people all around you
kind of like in the round type thing.
It was so hard to focus on
doing comedy when you're like,
have a little buzz going,
trying to do comedy.
Like it was just
uncomfortable like situation.
Well Cobbs is a great club,
right?
Even even though the new ones huge,
it's still,
it's a,
it's a bad ass place.
It's just,
it's so different.
I mean,
I do pay places that are bigger.
It's not that it's too big.
Um,
you know,
like I just did a,
the state theater in New Brunswick.
Oh,
was it?
it's amazing.
Anybody who came out to that show,
thank you so much.
That was like one of the best crowds
we've ever had ever at any show ever.
Really is amazing.
When Joey Diaz walked on stage,
I was kicking myself for not recording it.
It was,
it was so epic,
Dude.
He went on stage and
people went fucking crazy.
They went fucking crazy.
The crowd was intense.
It was so good.
It was just so,
it was perfect.
It might've been the best
side I've ever had in my life.
That's awesome.
Really.
It was.
It was incredible.
Incredible.
Did you eat good?
We ain't good at
little bit of mud.
Yeah.
This guy brought a fucking
bag filled with bread,
like five loafs of bread and a thing
of a [inaudible] mood set out cheese.
This gigantic fucking slab of cheese.
And I'm not bullshitting.
Was like two loafs of bread.
That's how much cheese it was.
And it was,
I didn't try.
Joey had it show.
He fucking,
he took that thing like,
like a,
like a bear bearing a
Caribou in the woods.
It's bread.
And what's that al?
And he took it up to his,
uh,
his room.
He ate the shit out of that man.
Yeah,
no,
it was amazing.
It does.
Uh,
thanks to Gino.
Thanks Gino.
New Jersey is awesome,
man.
At least that part was right.
It's interesting.
It's a,
it's,
it's weird.
You know,
because I was born there.
It's a weird spot.
Jersey's a strange spot.
Well anyway,
uh,
but we're going to say in the state
theater is much bigger than than cops.
It's like 2,400 people
or something like that.
That's insane.
It was awesome.
It was fucking awesome.
Is it just a different kind of show?
You know,
it's a,
but the intimate shows like the ones
that we do at the ice house and like
Sacramento,
that's the perfect,
I love Sacramento.
Perfect Room.
I want to try it.
And what I'm trying to do is like,
hopefully people come out to these shows
because I would like to do this at like
a month,
every month.
Like on their off night.
Just bringing a once a month,
bring a couple of comics up there.
Yeah.
You know,
and just good idea.
That's a great club.
It's a perfect size.
It's the perfect height.
It's just set up.
It's,
you know,
it's just old school,
old school,
Tight Club,
barn in the back.
Sacramento has the most
beautiful women in the room.
Oh,
someone's trying to get some busy.
I say what's up?
So easy,
Brian.
So easy.
No,
they are I Sacramento women are
fucking hot for some reason.
I think it's like all the guys that
have money used to go up north,
you know,
we had money and then all their
kids got molested and they all went,
I find northern California women
to be much more interesting.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I like to talk to them more.
I just,
I don't know why.
I mean,
that's,
so,
that's a massive generalization,
by the way,
you know?
But it just just seemed like,
I think here's the bottom line,
dude,
where we live is poisoned.
It's horrible.
It's poisoned,
it's poisoned.
It's poisoned with,
with like behavior,
like the actors and the,
the business,
the whole idea of the chasing fame.
It's like a giant Methadone clinic for,
for attention junkies.
You know?
That's what this area is.
It really is.
It is.
I mean you just can't,
there's no other way you can explain the
grand percentage of self absorbed Nim
wits that just does dumb people.
This isn't it.
There's no way to explain it.
Yeah.
And it really sucks hanging out
in certain parts more than others.
Like especially Holly.
We didn't even play the music yet,
but you know what,
we don't have to play any fucking music.
Let's not play music that's not playing
music as classes are over a bitch.
They've been over for a while.
Okay.
We don't need music.
Yeah,
sometimes we do,
but sometimes fuck it.
Let's get crazy this Brian,
you know,
this is a,
an idea we had talked
about a couple of times.
We haven't done one of
these in a long time.
Just,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
I've been,
and I would just randomly,
there was a thread on
your message where I'd,
oh wait,
I should probably get it to the cameras.
There was a thread on
the message board that,
uh,
that,
um,
people are like,
have you ever started the
podcast from number one?
And you were saying earlier,
like whatever episode,
this is like 300 something,
three 51 times that by three hours.
How many hours,
hours it would take you?
I think over a month I would,
I'm guessing a month.
In a week.
I would say.
Uh,
to listen to it straight.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what?
Podcasting,
sort of a highlights,
highlights,
highlighted.
So the word high lit for me
is how fucking crazy I am.
Like I never really knew how crazy.
It wasn't until we started doing these
podcasts and then a 351 podcast later I
realized like,
wow,
how did I even do that?
Like where do I even have the time to
do these fucking things between this and
Jiu Jitsu and comedy in
the UFC and family stuff.
This is how the fuck
do you even have time?
Like if I didn't,
you know,
if it wasn't me and I had to look at it,
I'm like,
Jesus Christ,
what's wrong with that guy?
Why is he doing so much shit?
You are doing a lot of shit.
Yeah,
but it's all cool.
Yeah.
You know you're going
to burn yourself out,
man.
No,
no,
I'm fine.
I feel burned out like crazy lately.
Yeah.
I mean
continue with working out.
As long as I eat good.
Stay away from the sauce.
Get off the booze kid.
That's ruining your life.
Yeah.
It's the sauce for sure.
Because if I,
if I have a couple go out to,
you know,
have a shot and a beer,
even just a shot in the beer
the next day I'm like Ooh,
not quite,
you know,
not like wrecked.
It had been a wreck for sure
last time it was wrecked.
It was Aubrey and I in
Brazil drink absinthe,
you know.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Yeah,
I did when we had our
shows up there that night.
Well you know,
we were there and just
buy some freak of nature.
There was these guys from New
Hampshire that were there too.
They weren't telling,
you know,
I think there probably were,
were there to see the UFC as well and
we all just started doing an absence
together.
Yeah.
Fuck that shit.
Yeah,
it gives you a weird hangover.
I got sick cause I got,
I was like hung over,
got to the airport,
felt like shit,
went through all the lines and all that.
So like my immune system was down at the
worst time when you're just swarmed by
other people's funk.
You know when you're at the airport,
man,
you're just,
you're,
you're walking into like a fog of
people sneezes and farts and sweat.
And especially when it was hot airports,
you know when everybody's taking
a jacket off and you're like,
Oh gee,
this is a fucking crockpot of
stinky farts and feed and you know,
it's all hermetically sealed.
You know,
the doors only open every now and again
to let people on a plane and a little
air sneaks in there
from that little tunnel.
But that's the only place
they're getting their air from.
It's a gigantic closed
off to but no windows.
It's the worst.
Yeah,
I mean that's,
that's the airport.
The airport sucks.
Smelling other people's
farts on an airplane has to
be the worst things ever to
show.
Diaz cut a fart so bad.
It made me write a blog about it.
There's a blog is a blog,
it's called,
um,
happy pills.
It's somewhere on my website,
but happy pills I wrote because a,
I was,
I was just,
I was writing this thing,
uh,
just,
I was just writing this thing about,
uh,
peoples,
the commercials for those antidepressants.
I don't even know if they're
allowed to do those anymore,
but they would have commercials where
people all of a sudden like had these
lives that were so wonderful and they
were running through fields of wheat and
they were leaping through the air and
there was doing these things that made you
feel like so happy.
And while I'm in the middle of writing
this Chili Diaz has kind of Fart that
could change the tides.
Like the ocean water would
hit the wall of Fart.
It would just go,
no,
no.
The only person that I've ever smelled
far it's worse is Tate and Tate.
Human taste,
legendary.
Many factions trying blood and just
nobody can go blow for blow with Tate.
I've cut some hard before in my life,
but I've just not worthy,
I'm not worthy,
you know.
But Joey did one on a plane and
I'm telling you the fucking,
the horror,
the horror of this woman behind me,
first of all,
I almost threw up in my mouth.
It was so bad.
It was so fast.
And Shelley fucking fan
the worst he fails
and he has no shame.
Like he'll cut a horrible
fight and go soup guy.
And then you just go,
oh you motherfucker.
Before the Fart hint,
I swear to God,
I felt warm
before it hit my nose,
but for the smell hit my nose.
I felt like warm air.
I was like,
what is that?
And then it hit me that
it was a fart and it was,
it was too late.
I was already breathing in
trying to figure out what it was.
Yeah.
And it just filled my mouth with this gas,
and this is a mouth because I
was mouth breathing back then.
I'm like,
oh,
it was blue cheese,
wasn't it?
It was death,
whatever it was.
That's why he likes blue cheese.
It's like I picture Joey
stomach as being like,
you know,
the amount of gas that it can generate.
Like,
if you want to have a
fart contest with Joey,
you got to lose man.
If he wants to eat when you eat,
you've got to lose.
You know,
tape was always eating them.
Fucking protein bars,
man,
you're but your body
doesn't digest those things.
Yeah.
If they don't and it just
automatically comes out.
That was the worst mandates was the worst
though because every time you hung out
with them,
it wasn't like normal
hangout with somebody else.
It was always about the farts.
Like you'd get in the car with us and
we'd all have to roll down the windows
because it was just nonstop fart
in the whole way to the airport.
And then we get on a plane,
it was off farting on the plane.
We get off and it's him coming into
your room and farting in your room.
And he was a big park guy.
Like he,
I wonder if you ever got that
w like fixed her and whatever.
Yeah,
I don't know.
So I got turned on to Paris.
Hilton's a vines last night.
And have you,
have you seen?
No,
they are probably some of the most
like,
I don't know like one,
I think she's pretty cute but uh,
they all have the exact same shit in them.
It's her like at a club and then at her
face and the exact same angle doing the
same faith that it's almost trippy.
Like almost like she doesn't exist
and they have somebody CGI her in like
different scenes with a green screen.
Like,
like check this,
let me,
right,
right.
See First.
So first there's what like one
just like you know like her,
uh,
hold on.
So it's just her like doing like these
weird like kind of my space angles and
then it's hurt at a club doing
like a little at the same time.
So she's showing like what she did like,
like a taste of that.
Could you see her face?
She's doing her at her side or angle.
And then you go to this other one that
looks like the same club but it's not,
it's from a too,
but she's trying turned
like the same shit.
And then here's another one.
Like,
it's just weird thing she is,
man.
She's such an odd,
odd,
famous person.
She's so famous.
I mean,
what does she's hated or not?
First of all,
I like her a lot.
I do not think she should
be hated by for any reason.
She doesn't do anything wrong.
She's not hurting anybody.
And that's how I felt when
people like shitting all over.
Yeah.
I don't know.
It's like,
you know,
yeah,
she's Vapid.
You know,
she's doing this.
Go into clubs and going out
and dancing and smiling.
But who's that hurt?
Who does that hurt?
You know,
the only,
the only argument,
and I could hear that I've heard
that it kind of makes sense,
is that she lowers standards for young
girls and she gets them thinking.
But you know what,
that's,
that's just a part of life.
People get bad influences sometimes.
You know,
I think if you,
uh,
if you have young kids and you communicate
with them good values and you try to
do the best to raise them
into responsible human beings,
everything after that is on them.
You know,
if your kid likes going to clubs
or kid likes going to clubs.
Okay.
And if your kid wants to be Paris Hilton,
this is like we're shit in life.
Right.
You know,
she's actually really intelligent.
What do you play crosswords with her?
No,
I intelligent of how she became famous.
You know,
like,
like what she,
how's she made a name of herself,
you know,
of course she made a sex tape.
Well that's been done twice now,
you know,
two girls got famous.
Right.
I mean that's what production was.
Cordelia was her buddy,
you know,
making us sex tape.
Little girls might not be a bad thing if
you want to be rich millionaire for the
rest of your,
I think the time for that as well though.
I think it's not shocking anymore.
Yeah.
That was a long time ago,
you know?
But what's interesting
about Kim Kardashian,
I said she like literally
there was no introduction.
No one knew who she was
before that sex tape.
But then she does that sex tape and like
she's one of the most famous women on
the planet.
And it because you don't release it
because like it snuck out somehow or
another.
It's okay.
Like,
yeah,
like we got reared rules when it comes
to sex tapes and the rules and the laws
are a lot different than
a lot of people think.
Like I heard a recent conversation with
Ari who's gonna be on tomorrow where he
doesn't believe that people
can't just release a sex date.
Like if you have a tape of Paris
Hilton and that guy fucking he,
that he thinks he could
just put on the Internet,
no one matters,
which is not the case.
A lot of all these sex tapes actually
have to be signed off by one of the people
in the Thi you know,
both of the people actually both of them.
Well,
I mean if you,
if you look at it like
does it vary by state?
It might be,
but if you look at porn,
they all have to have like the,
like the,
the right paperwork saying like,
this is like,
you know,
this person's over 18 years
old and stuff like that.
Right.
And so they can't,
you know,
you can't really just release and
sell a porn video without that.
So you kind of have to
have the person assigned.
Same like,
you know,
like yes,
that's me.
Yes,
I'm 18 and stuff like,
you know,
you can't just release
like a video and sell it.
If porn you have,
you have to follow the same paperwork.
You'd have to ask a real porn producer.
Well,
Kevin Blatt who's a friends with Sam
Tripoli and that's what he does for a
living.
You know,
he's,
I think he actually did the
Paris Hilton tape and yeah,
they people shop tapes to them and it's
99.9 always the person that's yeah.
Accidentally fell in this and it's me,
right,
with three camera angles.
Yeah.
I was reading Twitter the
other day last night actually.
And um,
I
have,
I fall so many people.
I follow a lot of weird people.
Don't ask me to follow you.
He asked me to follow you.
I won't follow you.
That's my roles.
Although I've said yes a couple of times.
Don't do it.
Don't ask.
It's gross.
Um,
uh,
I was looking reading through my
Twitter and it says anal loving ladies
lead need last minute
replacement for a scene tomorrow.
Get at me here.
Our tea please is from Seymour Butts and
I'm like looking down and like one of
my tweets is like a deep rock show,
Oprah tweet and the other one's like a
couple of MMA fighters and then sandwich
in between that and it's all in caps
with like little stars next to anal star,
Star Star,
anal loving lady,
Star,
Star Star.
All caps need last minute
replacement for a scene tomorrow.
That's how many times has that happened
where a girl just calls you up the day
before and he goes,
you know what,
you can't fuck me in the ass on camera
and put it on the Internet and this guy's
just like,
God damn.
And I had one,
I need that anal loving lady.
But do you think,
I guess he,
I bet bet he puts out that thing and
like immediately it's people like
contacting him.
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
I love it.
You know,
OMG
pretty cheap too.
If you need to make a,
if he really wanted to get laid,
you could really just make
yourself a porn company.
I've done that.
Yeah.
Guys have done that.
Guys have done,
I,
I met a guy who did that.
K a website where he would uh,
I forget what his website was called.
[inaudible] who would
like have sex with girls.
It would pay them,
have sex with him and he
was like membership only.
But this was like a long ass time ago.
Like I don't know if you could
get away with that today.
People don't want to buy anything.
No,
no.
I'm going to say you don't even sell it.
What I'm saying you could do it.
So it would basically
just be getting you laid.
That's what I'm saying.
Cause I know the rates for
different girls for working,
you know,
if they said that they would do it,
cheap
released the video.
Isn't it funny?
That's like a work
around for prostitution.
Yeah.
I mean essentially it's
a work around right?
Not that I'm against it.
I'm,
again,
I'm not against anything.
If you want to do it,
if it doesn't hurt anybody
else and you want to do it,
I'm not against anything.
I don't really care.
I think that this world is so weird and
there's so many things that people liked
it.
I don't understand so many things that
I liked that people don't understand.
Who am I to tell a chicken
not to be a hooker?
Right?
You know,
and who might've tell a
guy not to pay for sex,
how many guys had just been just fucked
over their whole life and it's just like
almost too late for them
to have a relationship.
You can tell me that guy shouldn't be
able to get a massage and get jerked off
for 50 bucks or 100 bucks,
40 bucks,
$40 what happened to the house?
That's what you hear.
It's allegedly allegedly at least
chain one to be very clear about that.
I heard,
but like if you think about it,
you know why?
Why shouldn't there be an option for that
guy where he can just pay for someone
to rub him?
Cause look,
I go get massages and massages are,
especially if you get it from someone
who's really good at it and it's like very
pleasurable,
you know?
And sometimes it's like a guy,
he's doing it.
It's like horrific.
No,
I never got,
never had a guy I would not feeling
that great pleasure from a man.
This is weird bonding thing going on.
Do you want to size naked?
Almost always with the guy.
Keep my underwear on Sun.
Oh No,
I always do naked.
I just,
in case I have to valley
to do my way out of there.
I got some little valley to those shorts.
I like Mario Sperry in the nineties
I was driving by a palm reader last night
and I've been noticing more and more,
I've been just looking
at palm readers cause I,
there's a lot of psychics here in la and
I remember it in Ohio here and there.
But the one thing I noticed,
they're always open my 24 hours a day.
It would be like two in the
morning and you have lights on.
It looks like they live there.
Also there's an open sign
and I'm wondering if psychics
are something that you
learn when you're older.
Like when you're like 70
or 80 and you're like,
oh no,
you go to a psychic to fuck.
You know,
like,
like I think there's something
going on because he was,
there's a lot of people,
you'd be really,
really surprised.
There's a lot of people
who believe in psychics.
Them why is,
see that's the thing and there's
things I don't understand.
Like I don't understand that.
I don't understand why doughnut drive
through places are so popular at foreign.
Like they're all doughnut places
are open on times at night.
You know,
that's this
Krispy Kreme and they open 24 hours a day.
I don't know.
But that's the only one that matters.
Krispy Kreme had a line,
I think they are like 40 people
deep last night in Burbank.
It,
they're doing it right.
What,
how's that possible?
It's just don't fucking delicious.
Especially because some of those freaks
who are real crazy Krispy Kreme people,
they know when the warm
ones come out of like,
I bet they have an APP.
If they don't have an APP,
they should have an APP.
The alerts,
you warm donuts within five
minutes because if you get them,
I don't want to tell you,
look,
if you're on a diet right now,
all I've eaten all day to
day folks as a Kale shake,
okay?
Be Clear about this.
For the most part,
I eat healthy and you should too.
But if you want a real next level
experience when it comes to eat and sweet
shit,
that's bad for you,
those Krispy Kreme donuts,
it come right out of the almond.
You could be there when it happens.
That's what it must have been.
God Damn,
dude,
I'm telling you,
they melt in your mouth.
You sink your teeth into them.
They have the perfect consistency.
It's not too firm.
It's not like a Brownie,
right?
You know?
But it's not like it's a,
it's a strange thing,
man.
And you take bites this thing and the
sugar level is out of this fucking world.
Okay.
It's covered in sugar.
The whole thing is glazed.
The outside glazes,
all sugar.
It's sugar.
And what old Carmel?
It's,
it hits you who just
turned the thing though.
That what happened?
That was weird.
Yeah.
What was that man?
My shuts off.
That was weird.
Anyway,
it couldn't taste any better.
It literally couldn't taste any better.
Jimmy was when you started
touching that iPad.
But that's not possible.
That's not hooked up to anything.
Right.
It must have been this,
I don't know.
Well,
whatever it was.
Um,
and that's probably what it was
because it was out of this road.
I was like,
there was a line out into the
street and into this busy street.
I don't want to encourage you to
have a new addiction on my guide,
but if you can go there,
go you,
we should go there and
you should go there,
sit inside this little laptop and
just do a little work and then say,
you just let me know.
And then warm months Kevin out
and those woman's come out.
You run after him.
It's funny because I
had to fight for them.
I want you to make a fine about it
because there was like six cop cars.
I like the [inaudible] six.
I'm like,
this is so hilarious.
Well,
you know what,
if I was a cop,
I'm out there freaking out all day word.
I'm going to get shot.
How am I going to come home to my kids?
I would enjoy a little sweet tooth too.
I would enjoy a little donut.
There's a reason why cops like donuts
because they have to reward themselves for
swimming around a world of Shit.
I got a new addiction,
Maddie gotta check this out.
There's a lot of different kinds of
apps that you can get out of your phone,
but one of the best ones,
especially since like this Boston Shit,
uh,
was uh,
looking at police scanners and I don't
know if you like dig into that or not,
but last night I was driving home and
there was so many cops in Burbank,
but there was,
there's usually like two cops in Burbank.
There was like,
cops,
like driving all over the place.
I was like,
something's going on right.
And so I turned on the police scanner
and my car while I'm driving and it's so
funny,
they were talking about me and I was like,
uh,
we had a black Volkswagen beetle
license plate and I'm like,
what the fuck are they sang?
And I guess they were looking for a car
and the cop just like kind of pulled up,
started driving next to me while I was
listening to the police scanner over my
speakers.
But they didn't do an end
up doing anything like that.
I don't even know what
they were talking about.
So I get home and it was so interesting
listening to that for two hours because
they were talking about
streets in my neighborhood.
Like this woman's like we have a break in,
she's hiding in the bathroom,
there's so many inside the house.
And they're like,
this is our seventh
time doing it this week.
She's an elderly woman.
There's probably not
going to be anyone there.
You know?
It's like they were just
like talking about it.
But it's so interesting to listen to that.
And especially,
it's interesting to listen
to it while you're driving.
You know,
late at night,
cause they will talk about
you on the police scanner.
It's so crazy.
And Freddy Loc actually uses it.
He says this,
this is pretty funny.
When he isn't like in a bad
neighborhood or something like that,
he'll turn on the police skater like
turn on really loud like speakerphone
style,
put it in his pocket.
So it kind of sounds like he has
like a police presence on them,
you know,
like,
so if people were like,
like who the fuck's this guy?
So yeah,
please.
Scanner.
It's a free out in his pocket.
People think he's got a radio.
Exactly.
Oh Mike.
Like that's a good idea for girls ladies.
Like if they,
uh,
if they,
if they're in a bad neighborhood,
throw that in your
progressive dude.
You're really turned on by cops
or hates cops are really bad.
Oh,
yikes.
I uh,
illegal.
Huh?
The scanner thing has to be,
it's on the IPAD.
How did it use to Oh yeah.
Right.
Yeah.
It's a real legit,
yeah,
there's tons of apps.
You have to approve those.
Right.
I think that's good that
apple approves apps.
I think it's bad because there's a lot
of shit I'm sure that gets censored,
you know,
like some fucking crazy ass hole once I
have like beheadings only as an app or
you know,
all the beheadings for the past year.
Cause there's always a bunch
of them on the Internet.
But you know,
Apple's like,
no,
he's sick.
Fuck you got to get done in your own.
There's a website right now and
that's devoted to Google apps.
I think it's created by,
I want to say bang.
[inaudible] we never talked
about Google glasses.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
that's,
that's true.
Yeah.
My friend let me try out,
uh,
her Google glasses and uh,
it was,
uh,
first of all it's,
it,
it was really weird because to be able
to try something out that no one has yet.
Right.
You know,
I think developers have them now.
Right.
Um,
and I'm going to get one,
but um,
this was,
this was a long time ago.
The first time I,
I saw them,
the law,
the first time I saw him
was over six months ago,
but the first time I tried him out,
excuse me,
sorry about that folks.
Jamie,
kind of cold and warm.
Um,
the first time I,
uh,
actually,
tried it out was this past
week and it was really,
they're really weird.
All right,
so they're like clear
glasses that cover up.
You're like,
no,
no.
It's just a frame.
It's a frame in,
in the right corner.
I don't know if it's a reversible this,
you could see that as
a picture of it on my,
uh,
my,
what is it?
Instagram.
I saw Louis Black this weekend and one
of the things he was talking about with
Instagram,
like how crazy is that?
They got $1 billion for Instagram.
It was pretty funny for
what Instagram does,
but I don't even know why is it,
you know,
I just started using
it because people say,
Hey,
do you have an Instagram?
I'm like,
I guess,
okay,
I'll get one.
And then Everlast made
us to start using it.
Yeah.
I started a not using it as
much lately anymore because of,
uh,
the other one.
How many characters do
you get on Instagram?
As much as you want anything.
So you can,
it's like a tweet or at least,
and then
click on it and they go to it.
And it's almost like a
twit longer with a picture.
Yeah.
Twit longer is annoying.
I remember that Shit.
Does people do,
people who still use that,
people still use that.
You're really missing the point.
So for real cause or reason,
yeah.
There's a reason why they're trying to
limit you to 140 characters because most
people are boring.
Verbose motherfuckers who just never
know when to stop and these crazy tweet
longer twit long or fuckers.
All right.
So,
okay,
so you see that my ride,
I see that thing,
that little piece of glass?
No,
no,
no.
There's no glass there.
That's just my face.
Yeah,
that's whole thing is exactly.
Exactly.
So it's not a pair of glasses,
it sits on you.
No,
it's like classes,
but there's nothing over one eye.
I don't know if they can make a design
that doesn't have like this because this
just looks like the from the jerk,
you know,
like the glasses from the movie that
kind of almost looks weird little thing
that you think you
see that you've got your cursor over.
Yeah.
That is the little little
window that you see everything.
And so you swipe it.
The way it works is by swiping
forward and swiping down and uh,
you talk to it and it
does everything on voice.
Say Weicker hand in front of you.
Like I did Google searches and it,
it worked like it was,
it was amazing.
Like I,
I,
like I said,
I think you say like,
okay glass or something like that.
Right.
And then I a God damn,
I got to stop doing that.
I'm so sorry folks.
That'll be the last one,
I promise.
Uh,
it's a bulletproof coffee.
It coats your throat.
I never drink bulletproof
coffee before I go onstage,
but I drank it before I do it
podcast.
Is that what it is?
Cause you've been thinking a lot lately.
It coat your throat.
Isn't that good?
Isn't that make it not Cough
Cause It's all oiled up.
No,
it's,
there's a lot of like you're this grass
fed butter in there and it gives you
this like residue sort of thing.
And when you start talking
it makes me want it.
Right.
So probably probably a bad idea.
How's your cholesterol and stuff?
It's all groovy.
Okay.
Cause that butter is not
going to fuck anything up.
No,
no,
no.
It's,
you know,
cholesterol comes from animal protein.
Oh,
okay.
What's butter than like butter does.
Some butter comes from animals.
Butter has a cholesterol,
but almond butter,
it's not butter.
Right?
Uh,
it's like,
uh,
it's like almond paste.
You know what I'm thinking?
Has any butter in it,
but almonds are a lot of fat in it.
I should actually find out
what's an almond butter.
Oh,
but the fact that it's in is good.
That's all good.
Fat Almond butter ingredients.
And you're like,
hmm.
Well it's actually,
there was a video that
I watched it the day.
It was kind of interesting,
but this one guy who eats nothing but raw
food and fats and he was like an older
guy and he eats raw meat and he was having
brought buffalo and raw hamburger and
he was uh,
he was just eating it and eating it
with chunks of raw butter in between.
Yeah.
What
now these are the Google glasses.
Did they record everything?
The whole thing.
Because there is a camp.
Looks like a Camry.
Take pictures.
I did that too.
I took pictures with it.
It's weird dude.
It's weird.
It will pull up this constantly.
Always recorded and everybody warm
because then that would be interesting.
Like during times of tragedy
everyone would have that.
It's like 500 people would have
their view of what happened,
you know what I mean?
It's a very interesting
thing to have them on and see like a
navigation screen in front of you of how I
did that as well.
Does it take over your whole vision?
No.
You'll have to search for it.
You like if I'm,
I can look at you right
now and that's fine,
but if I go like this,
there it is and then I looked at you,
I could see right through it.
But then I look here,
there it is.
It's a very small area or I mean it's,
it's not like you lose it.
You definitely can find it anytime you
want but it's a very small area which is
image exists so you could kind of
look around a way from that area.
That's why the idea is that you could
have them on and walk because you could
see everything.
I wonder if there's any long term effects
from that because you know like if you
think about like looking
at a computer screen,
you're straining your eyes cause it's
kind of close or are or a lot of people
tell you to look far away every hour or
so just so your eyes like focused on,
right.
I wonder if this becomes really popular
where there's going to be people just
constantly staring at that in there.
You're going to have a lot
of different eye problems.
That's a good question.
And then there's also
the radiation question.
Yeah.
Because a cell phones emit radiation
and most folks are not aware that um,
the,
you know,
when you,
you like if you go and
research what the cell phones,
uh,
what the radiation,
how much radiation it gives out
and what's an acceptable level.
Yeah.
Most,
most folks aren't aware that there's a,
that they have like a whole,
you know,
uh,
a list of like measured radiation
effects coming off of cell phones.
But one of the big ones is one of the
big weird parts of that is that you're
supposed to keep the phone away from your
head in order for it to meet with the
standards for radiation or
whatever the fuck it is.
It comes off of them.
You're supposed to have
it like right here.
So you're saying it's bad to put it on
speakerphone and black people are smart
ass the way smarter than us.
That whole thing went by the way we
talked about that on the podcast.
I got,
I got fucking angry
tweets from black people.
You can't,
cause it's not just black people.
There's white people too,
but it's only white people
who want to be black people.
You know.
Those are the people that also
talk in public on speakerphone.
Yo,
where you at dog?
Where you went because we're down
here holding it down at the mall.
I think it's fucked up because I do
wonder how many times I've talked to
somebody not knowing they were doing that.
And then I was like,
wait a second.
Yeah.
And you talked to shit.
Hey,
let's go get some gay sex.
Brian.
When to my mom and dad.
It looks like it's just
smushed up a almonds.
I think that's what almond butter is.
Well,
yeah,
like almond milk.
It's just almond.
Peanut water,
isn't it?
I don't know.
Maybe they had some shit to it too.
They must add some shit to it.
I don't know.
I don't have time to look at this.
Uh,
but there's fats that are good for you
and fats that are not good for you.
You know,
like the kind of fats you
getting like an Avocados.
Those are good for you.
Yeah,
and they still make me fat.
You have the fats are good
for you too if you need them.
Especially like the fat
that comes from animals.
So like,
um,
the,
uh,
whatever,
um,
is in,
uh,
especially like grass fed animal fat,
it's supposed to be really
healthy for your skin.
Like there's something about,
um,
certain fats,
you know,
and fats that come from animals apparently
have a positive effect on the elastic
city of your skin.
I don't know if that makes any sense,
but it makes sense to me
that it's so delicious.
It's so delicious.
Like your body must have some need for it,
you know,
and I know the cholesterol plays
a part of brain function too.
I don't know if that's totally
been misunderstood or understood.
Let me find out.
Cholesterol.
That's something that Oh,
people are always worried about.
Right.
Um,
and blood pressure.
I was my blood pressure dog.
Don't lie to me,
doc.
How am I doing over here?
Yeah.
I uh,
just got a physical reasonably
and everything checked out,
which is weird because I eat so random.
Like sometimes,
sometimes I do have pizza.
Some days I have Kale.
Some days I have,
you know,
what's that Kinlaw that never digested
it and when I wiped my butt it falls out
in a bunch of pieces.
Like it's trying to run away.
Well maybe that's your body.
You Digest Kale.
Like mine comes out like corn or keen,
I'm sorry Kim Wall like is it comes out
like corn style where it's like I've
even touched this shit
getting different kinds
of chemo than I am.
I'd have to look at your keenwah.
Ah,
Keith was salads before.
I liked that.
Those keen walk cakes.
Yeah.
Oh I left stuff.
It's one of the most
for as far as plant proteins,
one of the more complete proteins.
I think it's one of the few that's
actually completely complete.
I think it's like right up
there with hemp protein,
which is a very complete
protein for a plant protein.
Like some proteins,
they don't have all the amino acids.
I don't have everything that like,
uh,
like there's different kinds of proteins.
That's why like people that are
like strong Vegan advocates,
they uh,
especially like health and fitness nuts,
they recommend you mix up the uh,
the different foods and uh,
combined like different types of proteins.
You know,
like a,
you know,
like maybe Broccoli,
Broccoli,
it's like an incomplete protein,
but broccoli has protein
in it and you know,
then throw in the,
the powerful shit like
keen keenwah and Hamp,
both of them were like,
I think camp has all the
essential amino acids.
Pretty sure
you haven't had hemp milk the other day.
Okay.
If you have that stuff folks,
it does.
Just to let you know,
you don't fail tests,
you don't fail drug tests.
Right.
A lot of people worry about that.
Like,
cause hemp protein is,
it's so much easier on my body at least.
I love like muscle milk.
That shit is delicious.
It's delicious.
But that shit makes my asshole a weapon.
You know?
I,
like I said,
I can't,
I can't claim Tate status
or even Joey Diaz does,
but when I,
when I drank too much,
too much of that whey
protein that backs me out.
Here's my new favorite thing.
Uh,
you can actually get it on
Amazon at pack of 12 is $20.
It's Gogo Rice organic Chenwa and it's
these little little like they're already
cooked.
You just open up and eat it.
But what I do is yeah,
I put sprays,
so my,
I can't believe it's not butter on it
and it maybe throwing some Turkey Bacon
and I just put it in the
microwave there and it's,
it's like the perfect meal
and it's not bad for you.
It's good for you.
It's,
it's so easy.
It's like you can,
you could just eat it.
Like you don't even have to cook it.
It's already cooked.
It's great though.
So it's very good for you too.
Yeah.
And by the way,
if you know how to spell it,
you're an asshole.
You're right.
You know,
spell that.
No Way.
Unless you're a cook
or someone who deals
with it professionally.
Q u I.
How the hell do you know?
And if you know how to say it,
you're an asshole,
including me.
I'm going to ask all,
cause I know that keen was
like a pretentious food.
I think it's good.
I,
I'm a,
I'm a rice fan,
so to me it just to feel,
it tastes like rice.
I love it.
However,
there's a pretentious thing to it.
I don't know what it is,
but when you say I'm going to have
some keenwah I like to have some keen.
Woah.
It's like I picture you
with like wooden beads on,
you know?
Yeah.
Kale is like that to me because that's
just seems like it's completely out of
control right now.
There's tail everywhere.
It's a real superfood though.
Yeah.
It's fucking delicious,
man.
Except I've been hearing
it's dangerous to eat raw,
which is weird.
Um,
there's
people I think are worried
about is there's a small
percentage of folks that get
affected by a certain fungus that
can grow on chemo or I'm not Kale.
Right.
Yeah.
Let's see.
It's that fungus is pretty common.
Okay.
Hold on.
Let's,
let's pull that off and eat raw kale.
Kale danger.
Yeah.
Cause I just had some,
there's some really good
Kale going on at rollbacks.
I think I'm,
I don't know if we've talked about that.
There's a,
they have a lot of good Kale
smoothies or juices now.
Hmm.
Lately Tropicales the best.
Um,
I don't like Kale shakes.
You don't know.
But I like how they make me feel.
Yeah,
they're boring though.
I want to have,
I wanted to have bacon
and eggs this morning.
This is like,
that's the Robb wolf
style way of doing it.
Like Paleo.
But I knew how to work out in an hour
and the difference between Bacon and eggs
and a Kale shake,
his fucking tremendous.
As far as like your ability
to work out like afterwards,
like a Kale shake.
I could basically work
out right away in less.
I haven't done my morning Dukie yet.
Biggest,
if you get a Kale shake in you son you
are shitting within the next 20 minutes
whether you like it or not.
It's
coming out like it's
being chased by zombies.
It's like it's like World War z and the
toilet bowl and that's no bullshit man
that those Kale shakes.
It's just sludge.
You know Kale shake is just
green vegetable like a cleaner.
I was just like grinding out all the
stuff that's in its way just to a giant
blob of a universally sized,
so it's all like your your tube
instead of like chunks of meat and shit
stumbling down there.
It's,
there's no like chunks of anything.
It's one giant stuffed tube of green
liquid and celery and cucumber and garlic
and the garlic is just gangster,
just killing everybody.
Anybody that's anywhere,
it's like the Mongol hoards the get cause.
Garlic is like fantastic.
You ever have anything
wrong with your stomach?
Take garlic.
It's incredible for like food poisoning.
If you feel like shit,
you got a stomach flu,
eat cloves of garlic.
It's hard to do cause you chew
on those things and you're like,
Whoa,
like are a big ass rock clove of garlic
to just toss it in your mouth and start
chewing it.
It's pretty intense.
I know.
You don't want to cook it man.
You want it raw.
That's where all the nutrition comes in
that that's where the sting comes from.
As soon as you start cooking it,
you lose all that sting and I think that
sting of eating the raw garlic is just
what's just gangster just goes
into your body and starts fine.
It's like a fucking sword
wielding barbarian just
hacks up all the shit in your
body.
I think that's why one of my favorite
remedies ever for like anything that's
ailing my stomach.
Garlic just fucking cleans everything
out and you just the the shifts that come
out when you,
when you eat like cloves of garlic,
it's like literally like a bunch
of bodies being dropped off like a,
like a bulldozer pulls up.
Dean,
Dean.
It's just all dead bacteria that the
garlic assassinated inside your bacterial
tract.
Digestive tract rather.
Yeah,
we got it.
That's a weird thing that we have to
have those little things inside of us.
You have to have them.
If you don't have them,
you're sick.
You have to have a community in your body.
Pretty Weird.
I mean,
did you even know that
until you were like,
I was like 30 I think when I found
that out later than that for me.
But just stop and think about that.
Living your whole life
and then one day you go,
Whoa,
what's in me?
Flora?
What?
Skit?
Acidophilus.
It's alive.
Sure it doesn't that seem more important
to you to teach your kids things like
that instead of like Shit,
like uh Oh this guy read a horse until it,
the whole town people are coming and we
should do a whole report about this guy.
I don't know if we really knew
about it like when did they really?
Yeah,
but hearing the zooming body,
there's so many things that they don't
teach you growing up that are so fucking
important.
Like like credit cards,
finance charges and things like that.
When I got my first credit card,
I was still in high school.
I was like,
what?
$500 credit limit I could
buy whatever I want,
$500 laser disc player and then
the next thing I'm though I'm like,
oh,
I don't have to,
I don't have any money.
I'm not.
I'm just going to wait a couple months.
And next thing I know,
I ruined my whole entire
credit by the age of 19.
And you know why?
Because they didn't teach
that in high school.
They and,
and then credit card companies
just gave me a credit card.
Right.
Fresh,
you know,
but guess what,
if they taught you,
you wouldn't listen.
Uh,
Saru but I,
unless that at the end of the class that,
that we all signed up to get credit cards.
Well,
I think though that dat,
you don't also represents the fact that
that whole thing was fairly new back
then.
Credit cards and credit and credit
issues and people having credit problems.
It's fairly new.
You had been in the 90s.
I mean,
yeah,
but look,
I'm going to go a guy,
hi.
I know a guy,
his name was international sal and
I know I've talked about him before.
He was a,
a god that I used to know from my pool
hall days and he was one of the first
guys to go to jail for card fraud.
He,
uh,
was the first guy or one of the first
guys to figure out that you could take the
imprints,
like with some of them,
make a credit card,
you could take them and then take
that number and then go print your own
separate card.
And then when you print
your own separate card,
you just go off like a rocket and just,
you know,
you got your own separate shit printed
and you just start fucking charging up a
storm and then by the time
this guy gets the bill,
it's too late.
Well,
these guys would do that.
They would take these cards and then they
would buy things like gigantic things
and then they would bring those
things back and get money.
They'll go,
yeah,
you know,
I'll,
I,
I bought it.
I didn't like it.
So they bring them back and then boom,
they got all this money.
So they use these credit cards and getting
paid back cash or they're selling the
items that they buy.
Like they'll buy a car and
then sell it for 20 grand,
you know,
and sell it once they sell it to.
I mean,
I dunno,
I dunno how the fuck you can't track it,
but this was,
this was a long ass time ago.
I met the guy in 92 and he had just gotten
out of jail or maybe got out of jail
in 93,
somewhere around that.
And uh,
this guy made millions.
He was a loser at Campbell thing.
I mean,
I say that in the most respectful way
possible because he was a very nice guy.
What I mean is that he
would find a way to lose.
It was the weirdest thing
I've ever seen in my life.
He used to bet big,
big money and he would be down on the
ball and it'd be the very last nine ball.
You see his arm shaking,
he looks at it and,
but those are,
the dude just drives
it right into the rail.
And,
and you would,
you would swear that no one
could ever miss that shot,
but he would find a way to miss it.
And he played good pool.
He played good,
but he was just,
he was just addicted to losing.
It's like for whatever reason,
he had a psychological block that he
couldn't overcome when he came to winning
money.
I don't think I ever saw him.
Maybe one time,
I think I saw him win some money,
but that was like probably
somebody laid down on them.
Just kind of get them to raise the bet
for the next time and he would gamble
away millions of dollars.
So he would be at the pool hall.
Okay.
These guys would come and
literally with bags of money,
a key had the whole thing set up,
making the credit cards,
putting these guys in the street and they
come back with cash and they divvy it
up.
He said,
guys,
we're coming back with just
bags and bags and bags of money.
And so when you know people were
calling him international sal because
apparently they're buying shit and Paris
and Pine Shit in England and they take
fucking plane flights with these credit
cards and no one could track anything.
Back then you couldn't find
out who they were back then.
You got on a plane,
you didn't even have to show an ID.
You just got on a plane.
Like when I used to travel for DYC
winnowed tournament's when I was a kid,
I didn't have any ID.
He didn't need Id.
Nobody had ID.
You just get on a plane and go.
I'd flew across the country.
Just all,
I did a show up.
I didn't even,
I don't think of that.
I think I had a fucking driver's license.
I think.
Not only that,
if we got to the gate,
I was like,
you know what dude,
I don't want to go here.
Take my ticker.
You can go.
You'd be able to go.
You would be able to get
right on that fucking plane.
That'd be awesome.
The people used to sell tickets.
He's,
you'd be able to sell a ticket.
Like,
does anybody want my ticket?
I'm um,
you know,
you'd be able to put it in the paper.
Did you ever fly when there
was smoking on the plane?
Because I don't remember doing it.
Fucking Luli absolutely.
I remember that clearly.
Like this is,
I remember it being sad and twisted.
You know,
you're looking back at this whole cloud
of smoke and these people are absorbing
it with no recourse and the idea that
it's going to be contained in the back
area of his fucking tube of recycled air,
the three circulated this,
the same air is used over
and over and over again.
Like you're going to get that smoke in
your body no matter if you're in the
front or the back that smokes getting.
Yeah.
So these,
a little bit of it.
I uh,
somebody just contacted me
from my past the other day.
A dude he used to fuck no,
no,
no.
When,
when I was in high school,
I worked at this movie theater.
I was a projectionist and this other guy
that was in college and he was like one
of these guys that smoke.
He's the one that introduced me to
marijuana and when I was like 15,
like Vic,
careful what you say because that's
illegal and not going to say who it is.
Okay.
They might hold you
over the fire until you
all right.
And,
uh,
he's still,
but he used to like invite us to his
college parties and every weekend we would
party with college people
and we're in like 15,
16 years old.
We just got her driver's license.
I think I've told him in the past hygge
how I took all these shots I've ever
clear once.
And they got pulled over and the
cop gave me money for coffee.
You just told me to sit in my car.
Same,
same person.
That was when you were in high school?
That happened?
Yeah.
Oh my God.
What a crazy cop.
Yeah,
I know.
I crop was nuts.
I don't know.
Maybe he's just been there,
done that.
Yeah.
I also,
I,
I he probably,
I don't know.
But uh,
so th one thing I remembered though there,
I think they were all Italian,
all the guys like,
and uh,
the more you'll know about Ohio,
there's a lot of like mafia
and stuff like in Ohio,
but I,
I think I hung out.
I think they all were
kind of in that group,
you know,
looking back at it now you,
we're just super high and right.
Like a parent when
everyone's in the Mafia.
I know,
but just looking back at it,
it just seemed like it was,
but uh,
like,
uh,
he would have these like pretty big
parties every weekend and his friend would
come into town from Youngstown or
something like that every weekend.
And his sister was like,
I thought she was okay,
but she was not the prettiest girl.
And she was like little older than me.
She's like three years
older than me and he,
he would bring his sister down just so
she can fuck me because she doesn't get
attention or get any guys
from where she lives.
So I,
she would come in the room we hit,
they would come in there and be like,
and I'll be like,
oh,
hey,
how's it going?
And then later that day at
night would go up to his,
uh,
the guy that lives there
is room and would fuck.
And it was really weird because we never
else talked throughout the whole day,
you know,
and I just would fuck his sister forum.
You didn't talk to her?
Not really.
Just like when we fuck,
but like I didn't like
ever know her phone number.
I never liked in the
more I'm looking back,
I think I'm blocking a lot of shit
because I was thinking about
this because I was like,
why did I never get that girl's number?
Why?
But why did I never talked to her?
I would only remember I fucked her like
maybe 10 times and she would only be in
town once in a while.
And every time it was always like,
all right,
let's go upstairs.
And if sometimes that's just how it is,
that's the relationship.
Sometimes that's how it is.
Like you don't have a lot in common.
You don't want to talk,
but you like to fuck you.
But I remember him going
the first time like,
hey my sister,
you know,
would you want to go up there?
You want me to fuck fucker,
you can do it.
Trust me.
Do she wants it?
She can just,
she's very lonely.
She's nice girl.
And I remember doing it and then it became
a thing where every weekend he would
bring her so she likes some Dick.
And you were giving us some Dick.
Why you want to overanalyze things?
Cause it's so weird looking back at
shit completely blocked out your whole
entire life.
You know what I mean?
Like looking back like
why was I doing this?
Well not only that,
like your memories are so weird.
Anyway.
Memories or just whenever
it was once I was like,
I remember like the thick,
clearest things that I
remember ever in my life.
I could tell people but I can't say for
certainty how much of what I'm saying is
what I remember and how much I'm saying
is what I remember saying about what I
remember.
You know,
like how,
like like traumatic moments for one thing,
like a lot of people that have
been through some fucked up shit,
whether it's a violence
situation or you know,
a car accident or anything
where you really remember
it when you go back and try
to,
like,
especially if it's more
than like 10 years old,
if you go back and try to recreate it
when you're explaining it to people,
like if someone could see your memories,
they would go,
oh,
that's all you're working with here.
Like Jesus Christ,
she's barely remember
this fucking thing at all.
Like if I could see your actual memories,
I'd be like,
Oh yeah,
that car looks red and yeah.
Um,
you have some words that you've
memorized about what happened.
Um,
but your actual,
yeah,
you know the facts,
you know the facts as far as like,
you know where you were
and what took place.
But as far as like you remembering
what actually happened,
seeing it,
unless it's a while ago,
it's hard to beat off the girls
that you fucked a decade ago.
You think about that.
I can't,
do you think you could?
No,
no.
If you,
I don't think,
well you could,
I mean obviously you could beat off to
girls that you fucked when you were 16
but you're going to be making it all up,
right?
No,
I mean I haven't videotaping me has 15.
Don't tell the people
that do watch myself.
No,
it's illegal.
I think it's child pornography really?
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah,
watch myself.
I mean I don't have this video.
Well not only can you not watch it,
it's illegal for you to have it.
In fact,
it's a bit of my act that I'm doing
about a girl who got arrested for child
pornography because she was sending
boys in her class pictures of her pussy.
They arrested her with child
pornography and they had to um,
they had the,
they had a quitter of that,
but they,
they charged her with the use of a
criminal tool and that criminal tool was a
cell phone.
It says Solo masturbating.
So they can go after me.
What Watch,
I think it's illegal.
That would be weird.
Like really into,
well dude,
that guy,
that girl got arrested
like a really has happened.
So it's just one of those
literal translations of the law.
It doesn't make sense.
You know,
the girl she was sending,
the idea,
I guess is that she shouldn't be doing
that and they have to stop her because
pedos could get ahold of it
and just start beating off.
That's true.
That's what the idea is,
is that this boy probably has a big mouth.
Can't believe this girls sending her a
picture around everybody in the class.
And so,
you know,
next thing you know,
he puts it on,
you know,
I like to fuck kids.com and then boom,
hey,
whoever you are,
don't put,
I like to fuck kids.com and then
forward that shit to my website.
You sons of bitches,
she fucking dare.
That's actually a good idea not to stop
it in its tracks because I know someone
already thought of it like
finding domains and pointing it to
towards people and they're like,
oh,
look what he believes in.
It's a forward.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
that's one of the things that,
uh,
this guy,
I don't want to say his name because
I don't know what the fuck actually
happened.
I don't know what he's actually guilty of,
so I'll not say his name,
but he was,
uh,
involved in a,
a sex scandal and he
bought the domain name,
his name,
and then the word rape behind it,
like right afterwards,
so nobody else could get it,
you know,
which is kind of crazy like that.
And then,
you know,
everybody was like,
wow,
why did you do that?
Like,
like you're,
you're,
you're marketing your truth.
You know,
you're like when a guy like gets in
trouble for something and then you realize
that everything he's saying as far as
like talking about it and discussing it is
like a marketing strategy.
If he's like a professional marketer,
you know,
you immediately go,
wait a minute,
man.
Marketers,
that's it.
The whole thing is weird because like,
I like to know about cool shit,
you know?
And if I see a commercial
for like a new phone,
they're explaining to me
all the different stuff.
It doesn't like,
Ooh,
oh,
I love it.
That's great.
Um,
but when I see like scams,
like this same guy had this thing
promoting a player lifestyle and uh,
it was,
you were going to get advice,
it was like five grand for like three
days in Vegas and you were going to get
advice from this dude.
Who is this a super wizard
when it comes to economics,
he just knows how to do it and the
guy lives in the middle of the desert.
Like he's a wreck lose,
he never comes out.
He's a genius.
But you know,
I have to deal with this
bullshit because he's so smart
and he,
he is the reason why I'm so successful
and he can make you successful too.
And they're like,
then he has this email from the guy
and the email from the guy is like,
you know,
only send me real players,
not chicken shits and panty waist and
only people ready to push in all their
chips right now.
You know,
and this guy,
this,
this stupid thing that he said,
it turns out to be a draft.
So he never really received
this email from the guy.
The photo that he put on
his website is have a draft.
So people look at you like
you wrote that yourself,
like you wrote that yourself,
you made a letter to yourself pretending
you're this other guy who's this
economic wizard and you think I'm so
fucking dumb that I look at that and I
don't know.
It's a draft where it says save as
like the whole like and everyone's like
that's the,
that's a draft.
That's what it looks like.
It's on an email.
So he says he had addressed this because
if the internet goes crazy he says,
well,
which is good.
The truth is actually
stranger than fiction.
You're not going to believe this.
But this guy is so crazy that he didn't
want to send me an email with that
information cause he thought
it could be intercepted.
So he sent me an email of a
picture that he took of that email.
Okay.
Like how fucking dumb is that excuse
that you think that if someone can
intercept an email,
they can't understand an
email with a picture in it.
And a picture of an email
that's impossible to read.
Thank God you fucking good
precedent to jpeg form.
It's not like anybody has a jpeg reader.
What the fuck are you
even talking about man?
And this guy had this whole
scam planned before his,
um,
his,
his like situation blew up this,
um,
sexual,
we'll call it a sexual situation.
Um,
but watching that,
that little reading rather that
website that was dedicated to the,
to players.
Let me see if I can find it,
man.
I think it's like the
pure player lifestyle.com.
Hold on,
Catherine Zeta Jones just checked
herself in for bipolar disorder.
I wonder,
I wonder if that's true.
Michael Douglas is Dick for
10 years you would be bipolar.
I just say.
Or Michael Douglas is a pimp.
Like he's this crazy woman sperm.
He shooting into her.
What kind of pills he's on.
Poor girl.
Yeah.
Player lifestyle seminar.
That sucks.
It's,
it sucks whenever anybody goes crazy.
And that's uh,
that's a,
she's got to go to the
real player lifestyle.com.
She's still hot,
dude.
She was in a movie recently that I
watched where she played a lesbian,
a lesbian.
Um,
uh,
what was it?
A,
I'm like a therapist for some crazy bitch.
It was called,
I think it was called side effects.
Don't,
let's scroll up.
Scroll up,
scroll up.
Don't I want,
don't want to show pictures of
the dude's face but too late.
Well,
you already said the website.
I didn't say his name.
No,
no,
no.
I don't know what happened.
This is my take on it.
I don't know.
Yeah,
I dunno what the fuck happened.
But this shit,
this website's shit is not good.
It's not indicative of a
person to find character.
This is indicative of person is trying
to rip people off and you looking at it
and you see where it says,
it shows the email and look at the bottom.
It's like an explanation
for the email read.
It explains like,
why,
you know,
people say,
could you read,
I can't read that cause it,
when it's blown up on the screen,
I can't read it at all.
Uh,
the,
you want me to read the last thing?
No,
no,
no.
There's like a disclaimer like
why it's a jpeg of a picture.
Yeah,
I'll find it.
Don't worry about it.
I'll,
I'll find it.
I'll read it.
It's hilarious.
It's so stupid.
It's just so silly.
Hmm.
Interesting.
Yeah.
It's like the whole idea is that and
bought knowing that he calls the Guy Mr x
and the guy's photo on the website
is like a hat in front of his eyes.
It's so dumb.
It's like,
it's really designed for like
the dumbest of dumb people.
It's really designed for desperate people
that are like mentally challenged to
fundamental money making secrets.
I've held back for years and fundamental
moneymaking as all in capital letters
years is in capital that I'll set are the
most responsible for virtually all the
financial success I've had in my life.
The idea that people say like there's
a place that you meet me at this place.
Okay.
I'm going to tell you the secret.
I'm going to tell you how to get rich.
You know,
this could be done like the right way.
Well,
you could like have a seminar.
I'm sure they do.
Where you go when you talked to like
business experts who give you strategies
that you can employ in your business.
You know,
chances that you know or or,
or places where they tell you what
chances to take and you know what's a,
what,
what is play it paid off for them.
What's a good strategy as far as marketing
and like that's without a doubt you
can learn at a seminar
for something like that.
There's a lot of experts out there
that are really good at that shit,
but the type of person
that would write this,
this is not indicative of the type of
person who has like a lot of great advice
to give out.
This is the type of website that's
indicative of a person who's trying to rip
you off.
This is a trap.
This is the person who's just trying
to lie to you and get tons of cash from
you.
That's crazy eyes.
Well,
there's a lot of scammers ladder,
pyramid scams that have to do with
all kinds of listen to this when it's,
when they busted him on the,
uh,
on listen,
when they busted him on the,
um,
the,
the draft,
he goes,
some people asked me,
why post it?
Why is this a draft of an email?
I asked mister crazy
pants the same question.
Well,
now you go,
now you get to see even more.
So why he's such a pain in the ass ass
in capital letters and the truth and that
the truth is really stranger than fiction.
Dot Dot.
Dot.
He typed out the email,
his laptop,
crossed out his name and email address
and then turned it into a jpeg and send
it to me in a blank.
Email.
Blank is in capital letters,
blank email as if there's
such a thing as a blank email.
You told me that as a jpeg in it.
Let's just,
not blank.
I was like,
what the fuck bro?
And then he told me he didn't want to
send it as an email because someone might
intercept it really in capital letters.
Trust me,
he's worth the hassle.
But he's full on looney tunes.
He tried to determine what
the chain pag email do you do.
You know how,
how ridiculous that is.
Ridiculous.
Just just getting caught like that and
then claiming that that's what happened
is one of the nuttiest fucking
things I've ever heard in my life
and the fact that he like
put it out as a draft,
like it's almost like
with people like that,
that that to strategize how to rip people
off and strategize how to do shit like
that.
It's almost like they want to get busted.
It's almost like they feel bad doing
that when when it comes to something like
that,
like,
like pretending that a
guy that does it probably,
I don't even know what the guy exists,
but the guy definitely didn't write him
that email to pretending that someone's
writing you an email and if you read the,
the,
the email is hilarious man.
No bullshit attendees,
all capital letters.
So the guy,
the email is in the exact
same style of writing.
It's like,
it's a really specific style of writing
that I guess he doesn't realize.
He doesn't realize how specific
the way he communicates.
Like if I got an email from you,
I,
you know you have a style of,
of talking and writing.
Whereas if I get an email from my lawyer,
it's a different kind of style.
This is his all caps thing
for like emphasizing oh caps,
no bullshit attendees.
Seriously.
If these guys aren't real players who
aren't willing to push an all their chips
to the center of the table,
don't waste my time.
Like,
and this is Mr crazy pants.
This is mister x.
Like he can't even tell
you like who this guy is,
what his qualifications are.
It's not telling you anything.
The guys a rec clues.
He said genius and he's
responsible for all my success.
And if it's any one man that
I'm jealous of in his life,
it's him.
Whoa.
It's so ridiculous.
What the fuck man?
You know
how is looking at that broken toe?
Oh,
the Jon Jones broken toe.
Yeah.
That was a crazy situation.
It was not good.
Is He?
So did he break it like near
the end of the fight or he is,
we think we're not sure.
We only isolated when it turned over.
We isolated at one point in
the video it turned over.
Um,
but we did not isolate the exact break.
We have like a theory as to what happened
and it seems like he was ground and
pounding on Chael Sonnen and he was just
doing it so ruthlessly and ridiculously
that he's just pushing his
foot off of the canvas,
snapped his toe backwards.
Yeah.
Well when you think about it,
man,
it's amazing that we don't have more
tau injuries cause Tosa is little tiny
things and they're getting
involved in a fucking street fight,
you know,
kicking elbows and fucking
skulls and stomachs and you know,
catching shins.
It's like the idea that,
that this is the only
time this has happened.
It's actually kind of shocking.
I protect my piggies should,
it's a good move,
but you can't fight with
shoes on because you know the,
the texture of the shoe
would cut your face going.
You're right.
I think you'd deal with
a lot of Abrasiveness,
you know,
I don't think you could really,
I think barefoot is on
the only the way to go.
They could go with shinon instead paths,
but that doesn't protect your toes.
You know,
your toes are what they are.
They're weak,
you know?
And he snapped his toe
backward and it was nasty.
So I'm interviewing him
and I'm congratulating him.
They put his belt on them
and no one even knows it yet.
He doesn't even know it.
And then he looks down.
So he's like,
stands on a man.
It's like,
look down,
it feels blood.
He goes,
all my God,
my toe,
like he like he meet,
he immediately like,
it was like,
oh my God.
Like his toe was nasty.
I go,
oh,
okay.
All right.
So,
um,
nobody did anything.
That was what?
It was crazy.
No one was even anywhere near him.
Like I'm like,
this guy's got a broken toe.
So I have to,
because it's kind of an
awkward time for the doctors.
Like they don't know when to run in.
I get is the broadcast is going on and
obviously I'm talking on camera so they
don't want to like interrupt.
So nobody did anything.
So I kind of realized that since I'm the
one with the microphone and I'm talking
to him,
I got to do everything.
So I said,
hold on,
let me get him a chair.
I've got a chair and
I call for the doctor,
we get a doctor in here,
please.
And then the doctor run it in.
That's the only time I've ever had
a call for a doctor in a post fight
interview.
How did not see that?
He's such a trooper dude.
He,
he,
he wanted to continue.
I'm like,
do you want to keep talking?
We don't have to do this.
And he's like,
no,
I'm cool.
So I'm going.
So I said,
you know,
tell me,
what was it like,
you know,
was it like all the trash talking to get,
I don't remember even
what my questions were,
but when it was over,
um,
you know,
he,
uh,
he actually was holding,
his foot has one foot and
dancing for the crowd.
Like his toe was broken and he was holding
one foot and on his left leg he was
hopping around dancing for the crowd.
They were laughing and cheering.
Yeah.
It's toe got snapped and
he was laughing about it.
He didn't even care.
Then he ate a pizza.
You had a giant pizza,
sat down with this big ass pepperoni
pizza cause you know he has to cut weight
and then he went to the press conference
and then he went to the hospital after
all that.
Yeah,
they kind of stabilized foot.
They put it in a brace.
But um,
apparently,
you know,
it's broken toe.
It's one of those things that happens,
you know,
no one,
I'm no one uh,
Nu uh,
I think it's,
there's,
I think there's a theory that
you have to get like a broke,
a break taken care of
within an eight hour window.
Yeah.
So there was some criticism of that.
Like whether or not he should have been
allowed to eat that pizza because if he
ate that pizza,
what if he goes and into,
um,
you need 10 hours?
I think from the time you eat
till they let you go under
oh gas.
But I don't know if they had
to go and aesthetic with them.
I think that could probably go local
unless they need to do a real serious
ligament surgery.
I think they just went local.
I don't think they need to put you out.
Right.
But that's a good point because if you
eat and then you go and get anesthesia,
you could fucking,
you could throw up in your mouth like
you gotta have like a real issues.
Yeah.
Anesthesia is a weird thing,
man.
It's scary,
I've only done it I think once where
they tell you to count backwards or
whatever and then you
wake up and you're like,
where the fuck am I?
Like time?
Just that's time travel right there.
Don was my nose.
It's weird,
but they're so good at it now.
You know?
They know what the fuck to do.
It's a,
it's,
it's pretty incredible.
They can pop you under and cut you open.
You know?
They had to figure that
out back in the old days.
Dude,
they just gave you a piece of
wood when you bite down on it,
scream as they saw your leg off.
Okay.
Do you imagine having to do,
could you imagine dentists are this,
that the last one to like figure
shit out like Dennis Dennis,
cause they still have to do pretty
some pretty gnarly shit to you.
You know like grinding teeth down and
pulling teeth is what other options,
you know,
tooth teeth are the hard things
fucking off the eight years or so.
Well guys would get like fake teeth.
That's what's really crazy
that they can do that now.
Perfect.
They're like screw into your,
you have a fake screwing your channel Rod.
I have a Rod Rooney your mind,
your head Gaul and uh,
yeah and you know what they're doing in
Japan is that they're shaving them down
into like these like
little teeny fangs now.
They were doing that for a while.
Yeah,
they've been doing it for a while,
but I guess it's coming back
like cat teeth or whatever it is.
A Japanese people.
Well,
the good news is you could always get
caps if you decided to be a responsible
citizen.
Ways get the,
but that captures fucked up cause they
have to grind the surface or your real
teeth out all of them.
So yeah,
so that's a wrap.
You're not no more real teeth for the
rest of your life and they don't stay on
that.
Like I know this guy that was talking the
other day and they just fell out like,
oh yeah,
he was just eating noodles and it just
fell out of Diego Sanchez and Carl Breezy
and font and Diego Sanchez hit carp reason
I believe he hit him with a knee and
his veneer went flying.
Yeah,
it was nuts,
man.
We thought it was a tooth and we thought
a tooth came out of his mouth and went
flying.
That was a Diego Sanchez in his
heyday would swarm motherfuckers.
He just,
he had such tenacity and crazy cardio.
He was like the first guy that did that.
The Carl caught him with a big names.
We
thought it was a tooth and went flying.
I was robbing the,
highlighted it on the,
on the slow Mo,
you know?
Yeah.
That whole caps thing.
That's a weird day to not
have your real teeth anymore.
Just have this like I'm always
worried this society is going to fail.
I'm always worried and if
I had a mouth fuck caps,
I'm like,
God damn,
I got to keep these fucking cabs with me.
[inaudible] fails and we have no more
dentists and we're all going mad max
style.
Yeah.
My two front teeth,
my one of my teeth is only a temporary
that I've had since I was like sixth
grade or something like that.
Yeah.
I'm not,
I'm supposed to get rid of it,
but well your whole face is temporary.
Really.
How long is that going to last?
You know?
Fuck everybody.
You know,
we got like a hundred
years on this planet,
the whole thing.
Everything's temporary.
If you've added since sixth grade,
it should be like a contest feel.
Let's see how long.
I know.
It just might as well keep it.
Yeah,
why not?
Are you happy with it?
No.
I went to,
I do want to get veneers,
but it's so expensive.
How does it work?
Good.
Finnair's no,
this is what was your,
your fake tooth?
Yeah.
I'm not supposed to eat things like
apples and just the cut up apple.
It's like a little baby
and things like that.
I'm supposed to not eat,
but it's more just the staining issue
of drinking coffee every day and
cigarettes.
So it's,
it's probably so you want to get
veneers so that you could ruin,
ruin them to know so I can
have it like replace them.
So you want to have like all shiny teeth.
You want to,
I don't want you to model.
No,
I don't want that.
Like,
Hey,
I got white teeth.
Teague's yeah,
cause how you picture yourself in that,
that bikini.
No,
I just want to have like normal teeth.
Farrah Fawcett.
How about that?
Fair fossil,
that poster,
the big smile.
She dead rest in peace teeth upright now.
But back in the day she
had this big giant smile,
that fair
Fawcett poster.
You have the Farrah Fawcett poster.
Yeah.
I can't believe the classic iconic,
fair Fawcett her.
Yeah,
that's,
you know,
that's not good.
She got cancer.
That's Sachs does suck.
So that's hard.
I was looking at Pam Anderson's
Twitter the other day.
That's another one.
I just don't,
this is a weird thing that happens with,
uh,
some women is that they go from
being hot to being a monster.
It's really weird.
It's really weird the way they go
from being like really hot to almost
repulsive.
You know,
this like weird clinging on to like youth.
You remember we had the Angelina,
Angelina,
remember we were talking about
that and one of the reason podcast,
that woman who had billboards in La.
Yeah.
And what's weird is when we
talked about her the other day,
my friend had texted me that she
face planted and he filmed it.
Oh No.
And it was this right when
we were talking about it.
It happened.
That's so sad.
But
it is about TMZ.
She may TMZ though.
Hello.
Beautiful.
Oh my God,
he's here.
We're asking her how are you?
Look,
see how she covers.
Oh,
you okay?
Oh my God.
Okay.
Damn,
that sucks.
Yeah,
she seems Nice.
Your fault was it probably was hurt.
His fault.
She's paranoid,
she's getting out of their cars.
Guys got a camera in her face is
freaking out and says high curbs.
This high curbs should be,
you should probably pay attention
to where you're walking.
But she's not paying attention cause
she's got a camera in her face and she's
probably all weirded out.
Right.
Some guys going,
hey beautiful.
By the way,
if they don't identify themselves,
they don't say,
Hey,
I'm from TMZ.
They just stick a camera in your face.
You know?
And if you're sticking a camera
in an old lady's face like that,
she's a little weirded out by it.
Yeah.
She walks around with that,
that fan in front of
her face I should say.
Do eventually identify themselves.
Yeah,
but not before the cameras already on,
you know,
I fucked up my car one of
those curves the other day.
Those are,
there's not like the double curbs,
you know,
I don't know if you've seen where it's
like normal curve and then there's like
the really high ones.
So if you open your door,
yeah.
And that's exactly what it is.
Like somebody opened up my door,
I'm like,
what the fuck is that about?
Why is that even allowed?
That should be illegal.
The state should pay for that.
I wonder if it has anything to do with
like areas where they need to drain more
water.
Maybe,
you know,
or areas where that could
be like a real issue.
Right.
Most likely that's what it is.
Right?
You've got to make sure you don't hang
out with dumb people that just opened
doors like that.
Right.
Like,
you know,
dumb people just open your doors
slamming in the trees and shit.
Oh,
sorry dude.
Right.
Woopsies
did you talk about hate did at t here?
Oop,
I think there'll be did it on purpose.
I think he did it.
So you'd have something to talk about.
We'll just talk about it on the podcast.
But he did,
uh,
no thing just really opened up.
There was a card that was picking on me,
open it up,
and it dinged my door at Greeley hat by,
luckily it was like the day before you're,
my lease was up,
so I really didn't care.
I was like,
it's no big deal.
I got to bring it back.
It wasn't even,
he didn't even dig.
It just,
it seemed like it should have
like made a loud noise funk,
but it really didn't even leave a mark.
But you know,
I guess he talked about it on the radio.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I didn't get a chance to go
there this time I was in Jersey.
I was staying in New Brunswick because
it's too fucking far too much shit I had
to do while I was there.
I didn't,
I didn't get a chance to own a,
I gotta wake up and call them more often.
All right.
Just go to bed late.
I always look at the
beginning part of the show,
like it's always Joey Diaz tweeting
like about to go live and I'm like,
I'm in bed.
How's it going,
Joanne tonight.
Oh Joey.
When he's doing as a church
of what's happening now.
Yeah.
You
know what?
When people have radios in their cars,
that's going to be the number one
drive time show in the country.
When people have radios in their
cars that can play Internet,
which a lot of people do now,
but it's not quite 100%.
You know,
it's not quite,
you can get stitcher,
stitcher,
you can get in a lot of
Ford cars and you know,
a lot of cars,
a our Bluetooth sinked up to
iPhones and there's applications
that allow you to listen to podcasts,
like the podcast app on Itunes,
which is amazing.
I love that.
That's where I,
uh,
I get all my podcasts,
I listened to him,
but eventually it's going
to be even easier than that.
So you could stream live and when it got,
if a guy like Joey could do like a,
an internet morning
show and stream it live,
just get them every day from,
you know,
six to nine.
He was doing something
about the national anthem.
Didn't we play it?
We played it.
Yeah.
Come on man.
That's funny than anything you've
ever heard in any fucking mornings.
Who ever,
well,
I don't know if you stand up,
get up,
get up.
Uh,
Volkswagen just announced their new,
uh,
crazy,
I beetle.
I don't know if he even heard this.
It's a doc and an APP for your iPhone
five Oh like right there and it integrates
in with your iPhone so you can just sit
there and use your radio and like access
things like Spotify and stitcher and,
and you know you're going to be able
to do whatever pretty much whatever you
want to.
But it's,
it's,
it's coming out in the next month
or a couple of months I believe.
And it's like the first time that there
is actually a car that I think has maybe
worked with apple because they,
they're using some kind of
software that integrates with,
I'm not 100% sure about it,
but the people are making it seem like,
like they were,
there was actually some
kind of three pedal car.
That's my car
though.
Yeah.
Go back to that though.
Is that a manual transmission?
Did they still make these things
with manual transmissions?
The beetle?
Oh yeah.
There's manual.
There's also been that
one that you saw there.
The iPhone five one is that
it's not a stick shift.
Yeah.
That's a stick shift.
I can't believe they even advertise that
I thought looked like smooth most small
car companies.
I thought they were done with that.
Oh,
mine's a turbo.
And the,
actually they have a diesel turbo now,
but it's also got the paddle shifters.
But this is,
yeah,
paddle shifters.
It means it's an automatic,
that's what I'm saying.
Like the clutch lists,
uh,
these dual clutch boxes where you don't,
I mean I'd been clutchless like
you don't press it yourself.
Automatic Clutch.
They still say you saved money.
It's just an La,
you don't see it that much
because I think you do.
I look gas.
I think you're supposed to.
That's what I mean.
I'm gas.
I don't think you do anymore.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I don't,
I don't think it's more efficient anymore.
I think the manual is less efficient
no more.
I'm sorry.
More it costs less.
Oh,
to buy it.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
definitely.
It's like,
it makes sense.
Yeah,
usually.
Yeah.
Automatic transmission.
For a long time it was like a big,
a big amount.
But I remember when I was a kid,
like everybody wanted automatics.
Like it was like a big deal.
Like we had a muscle car.
You want her to get an automatic,
I have no idea why now.
Like I had a muscle car that was an
automatic and it was like so annoying to
just,
it just,
it's doing the shifting for you.
Like if you're going to drive
one of the stupid old cars,
you should be doing all
that stupid old shit.
Like shifting your own gears.
You know,
you should probably roll
down your own windows too.
Yeah.
My friend took windows,
like self parking cars the
other day and it crashed.
No.
Yeah,
it just started like,
I just like ran right into the
car that it was trying to park.
Oh no it was it Alexis.
Who,
no,
I don't want to
that Lexus is a fucking,
that was the first one that invented it.
That is a smooth ride.
If you ever want like a
sort of low key luxury car,
like it's not as in your face
is like a Mercedes or is is uh,
as flashy as a Bentley
or something like that.
But you're inside that car,
you don't hear shit they had,
it was one of the most
comfortable fucking cars.
Lexus knows how to make like
this weird sort of environment,
this weird like soft,
calm environment like that.
Carl calm you down.
You ever be in a,
you ever been in like a
really expensive luxury car?
Just yours.
That old BMW?
Yeah.
I don't even require those anymore.
Yeah,
but they're,
they're not,
I don't have any luxury cars anymore.
That's true.
Luxury cars are weird.
Like the calm you down and this troubled,
I was Lexuses.
It's the ridiculous,
you don't feel anything.
Everything you go over,
it's like you're on a boat.
Like you don't feel bumps and shit.
It's like,
it figures out a way to
smooth everything out.
You know,
like he made you feel some major ones
but it's like slowly removing the feeling
of the road from the driver.
All this is electronic filters.
Some people hate it.
You know,
some people that like really like cars,
older cars,
they'd love the fact
that you feel everything,
you know,
you feel the road,
you feel bumps,
you feel like the steering is alive.
You know these cards today,
like a lot of them they're starting
to make with electronic steering.
So there's no,
there's no difference.
It's not more difficult
to turn like under stress.
It's not like you don't have a feeling
of like what the car is doing as you're
turning.
It's like a numb feeling.
It's really kind of strange
because that's weird.
Yeah.
Like do you remember power steering
like old old car power steering?
Like did you ever have one of those old
like American cars?
I had the one and then one time it went
out in you're trying to dry and you have
to like to sit there
and try to turn it off.
It goes out.
Especially if you have to park.
Yeah,
look stupid.
You're never going to figure out
a way to get an impala and do it.
No
parking spot with manual steering and
you have to fucking John Rollo arms to
pull that off.
But the,
uh,
the vagueness of that shit was so weird.
Like you would,
it would have like play
like left and right,
like serious play.
Like you could go straight,
you could go like that and go straight.
Oh yeah.
Like no problem.
You know,
it's like when you wanted to turn,
you had a really cracked up bitch,
had a station wagon,
a Ford Fairmont or whatever
it's called state wood panels.
I was like,
well it's also the designs that they made,
although they were really cool,
like the dodge charger.
Like they,
they made some really cool designs and
like the 60s and when they were making
those big giant cars,
but they're the most
Anelle dynamic you could
think of.
You know,
that big giant funnel and
the front of a dodge charger,
like that dukes of
Hazzard car that they had,
that front is like,
it's like running with a
bucket in front of you,
you know,
and the buckets like
soaking up all that air and,
and,
and you know,
and it's not sleek at all,
but they look so bad ass for the time.
That would even consider the fact
that the aerodynamics were dog shit.
They didn't know.
They didn't,
I mean they sort of realize
it has to be kind of low.
It's better that way
and it's flat and just,
but they didn't like have air tunnels and
shipped back then when they would look
at the way the air flew over the
body and have a coefficient of drag
reading to give each car.
Yeah,
I miss bucket seats the most like being
able to just like sleep in your car back
or on your car without having
to worry about stick shifts.
Things in the Middle and
cup holders and yeah,
I remember cars,
whether you would just hit that
lever and it fully reclined back.
Yeah,
I have a bed in your car.
you have a bed.
Too many people were fucking in their car.
They noticed that the,
the sex rate and a birth rate was
going up so they removed those from the
population.
It's a government,
it's a nanny state.
I do think eventually it one day
I went to buy like legit van,
not like minivan,
like one of those vans that
your constraints parents
always had that you were
like this is bad ass.
I was like being in the future.
Did they even make those anymore?
What,
what company was that that made
like the really tight big band?
Well those are conversion vans.
I think you're thinking it
but there was a bunch of them.
It Fords and Chevy's and dodges.
But I think it's a weird thing that
the van is in popular when the SUV is,
you know,
people like SUV cause they were big.
You can put a lot of stuff in them.
There's plenty of room but and
nothing big like a van side.
I made a van,
it's like a giant truck,
like a bakery truck with
a couple of seats in it.
I say do they make vans?
Of course they do.
They use them for work.
We've um,
we bought them or we rented them when
we were on the road before you remember
we're in Houston.
We were like,
fuck it,
let's get a van.
It's going to utility van.
There was too many of us.
That was back in the the Hay day,
the initial,
the initial death squad weeks,
there was a,
our,
our numbers were vast and we were going
from town to town doing these gigs and
we'd bring like five,
six days with us.
We had to figure out a
way to transport people,
so we got it fucking cargo van to him.
I might buy a van,
I might sell my four to
edge and just by van.
It's not a bad idea because first of all,
you travel around with a lot of equipment.
Sometimes you know you'll have plenty
of room in there and you can do anything
you want inside.
You could deck it out like an NSA.
That's right,
Pam.
Good Dude.
You could have a fucking flat
screen in there and the seat,
she could pull over places if you
wanted it to and watch television.
You could have satellite on your
roof of podcasts in the back.
Totally have a podcast.
We could have a mold
podcast studio rather.
There's no problem if there's any
TV shows that are still pimping.
Shit.
Let's think that right there about
us developing a podcast studio van.
Okay.
Don't van.
I'm for it man.
Honestly,
what's cool about that dude,
we could go anywhere with that.
We talked about it once before you doing
when those silver bullet aero stream
one,
like a small one.
I think just having a really nice van,
like a comfortable one.
Cause at my,
my friend's neighbor had one growing up
in the 70s and I just remember it had a
curtain that divided it from the driver.
It was like there was like a bed where
you could like take these two couches and
put them together and it made a bed
and it had like a little disco ball in
there.
It was pretty much like a shagging wagon.
Oh you could totally get that.
Yeah.
But you could also get something where
it's a party bus or like say you pull up
to places.
Like we'd say we could
do a podcast and say,
hey,
we're going to be,
you know,
at this place you will and
we'll put speakers on the
outside of the door and you
guys can hang out and watch.
While we podcast quite out there,
you fucking savages.
While the thing is plan,
like you know how nutty that would be,
dude,
we had a van.
Okay.
With broadcast speakers and we
pull up to like certain locations.
Like we set it up that we're
going to podcast places.
We have chairs laid out,
bad ass.
Is there any of those shows on TV anymore?
That dude,
that shit.
Well let's think about this.
Yeah,
we can.
I know some people.
All right.
I know there's a dude who
does a lot of car shows.
Man.
He's the one that did rides
and overhauling my friend bud.
I could sell my Ford
edge and then go to like,
like a used car dealer,
buy like a big van and
have them pimp it out to,
we could even,
we can't really broadcast on Ustream
from one of those fucking yes.
Yeah.
We can't really get bandwidth high enough.
Now.
We could get bandwidth.
This is exactly what
we're doing right now,
which is okay.
Remember we did it.
Uh,
we broadcast me,
you and Greg and Sam and
Seattle,
uh,
eating the,
you know,
a couple of right.
When you do that with your,
well that was walking my iPad.
No,
that was just my iPad cellular iPad.
Oh,
I thought you were using the
hotel's Wifi and it wasn't.
No,
it was just the cellular.
That's right.
Yeah.
That was a widow.
Those Samsung things.
Right.
Look at this.
Look at this dude inside of a van.
Check this shit out.
It's Scooby Doo.
Live in that one.
Oh,
look at that.
You know,
that's fair.
There's Imax to bill into the
fucking the wall and that's the side.
Wow.
It's just mounted the watermelon.
Yeah.
Dude.
Dude,
look at the,
we need to get one like Scooby Doos van.
Oh,
look at that.
Pull that one up.
That one with the door is
that guys got up the same one.
She looking at the same one.
Pull up.
Pull it up though.
That photo.
Yeah.
No,
just the photo of him at the door
in front of the door like that.
See,
I was on understanding the,
how it was set up.
Now I see it.
Yeah,
cause that's the door.
See I would want it more couchy
and loungy but with cool stuff,
you know what I mean?
This looks more like a mobile workstation,
which is cool.
But I think it should be more likely,
right chillaxing pad.
Totally right.
It should be like super comfortable
couch and a flat screen and us with
headsets.
So like we're like semicircular.
I liked that aspect of it.
Right.
And my circular phasing
a monitor on the outside,
it should look seventies and just
tinted windows so it doesn't look like,
it's like,
I wouldn't want it to be like,
hey everyone,
look,
you could steal this.
And there's a million Mac imax in it.
And there's also urban
people that I have to say,
look that sober.
He fucking got
tagged up.
You know what I mean?
So it's like attracting like,
oh there's probably some
good speakers in this.
You know what?
I know if you had access to
porn stars and I know you do,
you could bribe them to blow David Cho
and maybe he would paint something on it
for us.
He's a bad ass.
I'm mad.
I'm mad man because that's
just too much painting to do.
He doesn't have time to paint a van,
but,
well I'm upset because David Troy
was on Korea town episode of Anthony
Bourdain's show on CNN and it happened.
His episodes was the same weekend it
was supposed to be during all the Boston
bombings.
So it recorded like 30 minutes of news,
you know,
like Dvr and it just didn't record.
It just skipped it.
And so now there's like no way
that I don't know how to get,
it sucks.
How is this new show?
I haven't seen the new show.
Yeah,
it's pretty much just like his old show.
He just goes to like different
cities and stuff like that.
It's pretty good though.
I,
I mean I wanted it to really see the
Korea town one cause Korea town's really
cool.
Like there's a lot of weird
things and Korea town,
like there's like a club called the key
club where you just all these like doors
and you have to have a key
to get in like a speakeasy.
Wow.
There's a lot of weird karaoke bar place.
This girlfriend,
have you heard of?
Uh,
these clubs?
I think they're called girlfriend.
Girlfriend clubs.
Yeah.
Where did these two girls just
sit down and act like your,
your,
your girlfriend for the whole day?
I know dude who went to one of those?
I think they're,
what are they called?
There's,
there's,
there's no,
there's another name for it
or companion companion club.
Companionship clubs.
That's what it is.
It's really weird cause
they were pretty girls.
There were essentially gold diggers.
Right.
And they were like hoping that they would
run into some like rich dude there who
would take care of them.
I think there was a lot of that going on,
but it was also probably a lot of like
low level planning for prostitution.
And then there's probably some
legit girls who just needed a job.
And if I have to sit there and talk
to this fucking loser for two hours,
a lot of models do it.
I,
I know some of the clubs,
like there's a couple of models,
I know that Asian models and they're like,
no,
you know,
that's of legit job.
Like they pay you $100 an hour to,
you know,
just to sit there and talk to him.
No,
no prostitution at all.
So it depends on which one is
the 20 goods clubs you go to.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
I knew a dude one to one of those who was,
he was like a sad case.
Poor guy,
couldn't get a girlfriend,
he never could make it happen.
So he would,
uh,
he would go to these things
and hang out with girls.
I think if she had to pay
him x amount per hour,
right.
To sit with you,
I would almost go because I like Asian
girls so much and they always Asian.
Most of the time they are like,
I don't feel it.
I think they're the only other
one I've ever heard is Russian,
but it's more
mostly Asian.
And he said that
some of it was like married dudes would
come in and just didn't have anybody to
talk to.
They'll come in and talk to these young
pretty girls and then that's all they
wanted and then they would leave.
Right.
All right.
Happens in strip clubs everyday.
You know?
True.
It was,
but they keep their clothes on these
places so he can pretend it's a nice girl.
It's so weird.
I kinda want to try.
I like that shit.
I like trying that shit cause he's,
the stories come from that shit experience
comes from it and then you think of
things he never thought of before.
You know,
I like doing that weird shit.
That's why I like like trying all
these weird massage parlors lately.
Like it's weird to me that
that lifestyle even happens,
you know?
It's a,
it's very weird.
And what's weird is how taboo
it is and this stupid country,
everyone's so freaked out about it.
This is what we need brother.
We need to get an 18 van,
make it look like the 18 oh fuck yeah.
That's what it is.
Have it exactly like the 18 van.
That's the shit right there.
And do everything that
the 18 van has on it.
Like a winch.
The big thing over the grill,
big metal shit.
Actually no,
we shouldn't write.
We should come up with her own shit.
We can't have the desk walk cat on.
I can,
no,
I want it to look kind of like,
like I was saying like seventies,
like you would just drive
by and they're like,
oh,
that's just an old van.
You know what I mean?
Scooby Doo van.
What's it look up?
No,
that's like fluorescent green with
flowers on it and orange pedal.
Whereas this,
there's a movie I saw the other day,
uh,
about these two prostitutes from
Amsterdam and there the roads,
they were like the
oldest prostitutes ever.
Oh.
And they said that they saw more
than 355,000 clients to date.
And they're,
they're twin sisters and there's,
uh,
oh my God.
Are you kidding me?
Yeah,
they just retired the other day,
but there's eight.
Just retired.
Yeah,
there's a,
there's a Netflix.
Uh,
yeah,
a movie all about them.
Uh,
documentary,
uh,
the Scooby Doo van for
sale on Craig's list.
I know there's a lot of
those because of the law.
When the movies came out,
this could be good.
One,
two,
and three.
They had a bunch of these
like advertising vans,
so these ladies,
these ladies.
But anyways,
it's a,
it's a really interesting,
uh,
documentary.
I can't think of the,
see,
see if they say what it is,
but they're,
their name is Louise and Martine
focons and their sisters that had been
prostitutes for over 50 years.
And,
uh,
it was the most creepiest documentary
because they talked about how they didn't
really want to do it anymore.
They were kind of,
you know,
like,
I'm an old lady,
I don't want to do this.
But then they had to because they had no
other choice because they had no money.
And uh,
if you can look that,
that,
but,
but what was crazy,
it's like she sat in the window and
she had to put on makeup and a wig on.
She put her little cleavage out in these
windows and they just have these chairs
and the windows.
I've never been to Amsterdam,
so I've never seen this
where they sit in the window,
kind of like a puppy in the window.
They're like,
you know,
making kissing noises and like,
hey,
why don't you come in here?
You want to fuck,
you know,
like,
and these old ladies were doing it
and they would still get clients.
You know,
everything cause like you'd walk by like
these kids would walk back and like,
Hey,
you want to flip that Old Lady?
What she said
is what she said.
I was a little tired.
That's her quote.
I,
that was the first club.
I was a little tired,
tired.
Luis told as it happens.
Host Carol off in an interview that
aired March 18th the sister said that old
age and arthritis where the main reasons
for their retirement and I've written
about their exploits in the new
book called the ladies of Amsterdam.
The ladies of answers.
Yeah,
I think that's the name of the movie.
Awesome.
Maybe fucking name.
And it was really interesting.
Like here's some photos of
them sitting in their window.
See like,
here's,
here's like the little window
in front of the door crunched.
Is that them?
Yeah.
Oh my God.
That would sit there with
a big jacket on like that.
It's,
oh,
it's called meet the Falcons.
Oh my Americans.
Oldest prostitutes who
get that got it on her.
I mean,
they used to be,
you know,
Ralphie may look at that.
That's how they would
walk down the street.
And the documentary was kind of cute.
Does it?
Cause there was so such an old ladies.
Oh my God.
But it was awesome.
Really disturbing.
They look like dude's
pretending to be old ladies.
Like one of those theme movies.
Pills.
Yeah.
They look with Dustin Hoffman.
Yes.
Yeah,
they do.
They look,
yeah,
they look fake.
Yeah.
Look to Benny Hills and dresses.
I know.
Wow.
But,
and the darkness that they must have
seen how much people they fucked.
Just think of that.
The weirdness that they must've
seen in sucking 350,000 Cox,
she's just think of the herpes they have.
They could probably got mostly her B.
That's why they were red.
It's just a big heart.
It's like the right hat club.
They're all like,
their body just becomes like a
battleground and all the Siv,
HIV,
s,
t,
d,
syphilis,
gonorrhea,
aids,
it all just battled it out
together for dominance,
see who wins.
And meanwhile she stays healthy.
She's tastes healthy cause
they didn't attack each other.
They don't even go after the immune system
is going to be,
it's me out.
I mentioned that with your kids.
That's when it would really gross you out.
Imagine if you,
uh,
had a kid with a check and then you
weren't really that into it and you'd kind
of like kept away from her and left and
didn't pay child support and she went
into property and then you found out
many years later that your kid retired as
the oldest prostitute ever in Amsterdam.
You know,
man,
you want to talk about
regret at someone's,
a little girl that
someone's a little girl.
That was someone's little cute baby that
was so sweet and everything she said
was adorable.
Oh my goodness.
Look at her.
She's so precious.
Next thing you know,
it doesn't really end that well.
This story.
Well,
how did it end?
do you really want to hear the end?
Yeah.
Well,
they became a prostitute
for 50 years and soc 350,000 decks,
both of them and they're twins.
God Damn,
that's hardcore,
man.
I've always wanted to have twins.
Have you ever known someone
that's been a prostitute?
It'll be able to,
well,
yeah.
You know,
a few of prostitutes.
What is that?
Is that it has to be one of the weirdest,
well,
the girl I knew in Ohio that the first
girl I ever met that was a prostitute,
she was like,
I girl that tried to be
a porn star from Ohio.
She would come to la once a month and
stay there for a week and film a bunch of
Shit and then come back.
But when she came back,
I mean she made all this money from being,
you know,
making all these movies and
fucking and fucking people.
But when she came back she was like,
all right,
I don't want to be a stripper
out or anything like that.
So she would just do like the,
the escort shit.
Ooh.
You know,
she did it,
uh,
quite regularly and she was just making,
I mean,
she had more money than anybody I knew.
You know.
I mean,
she had like the best
house in Ohio at Ohio.
How many
our age group meeting.
Like she had like a really nice fat place,
you know,
compared to like all of us who are
like living like five guys in a fucking
right.
You know,
it's kind of crazy isn't it?
It's crazy that you can massage
people but you can't massage decks.
Right.
Cause that's essentially
what being a prostitute is.
Because people love to have sex,
right?
They love def sex.
But if you love to have sex and
someone gives you money for it,
that somehow or another illegal,
well people love to get massages,
love given sizes.
Uh,
but the massage is only good
for one person or you know,
if you're a chicken loves Dick
and you're getting fucked,
you're actually,
it feels good for you to,
a massage is actually more
like prostitution then even
prostitution because it's
just some one person.
You're not even having sex like a blow
job I guess is like prostitution or like
a hand job.
Well what if like taking like you meet a
girl on a blind date and you'd take her
out to dinner.
He spent all this money on drinks
and food and then you go and fucker.
What about just not drinking the food
or eating and just giving her the money
and skipping that part like
it's like the same shit.
Brilliant nanny state government
is trying to encourage marriage,
friendship.
They want you guys to
really like each other.
Why don't you really like each other?
Why don't you be sweet
to each other for real?
Did Not do it for money.
You can't do it for money.
Can't do it for money.
You know why he can't do it for money?
Because I can't trust
that you're going to pay.
You pay the taxes.
That's why,
and then also it looks bad.
If politicians pass laws and
say prostitution's legal.
Then people go,
why do you want that?
Huh?
Eliot Spitzer.
It's caught a better name like and
kisses companion kisses on my Dick.
Jesus hugs son caught Jesus hugs.
She's just hug.
It's a weird thing that something
that people love to do it.
It's like a freely CD thing.
If you get paid for it,
that's weird,
right?
But it's not everywhere.
Our country's attitude
about it is archaic compared
to the rest of the world.
Completely archaic.
Our country's attitude about all kinds
of things just about sex and nudity and
and especially when it comes to women,
men for women.
I think our country treats women
that are into Saks and enjoy sex.
They frown on them so much
in comparison to like Canada,
like Canada,
like girls that you meet from Canada,
they're like way cooler about sucks,
like not obviously massive generalization,
right?
Vancouver,
plenty of really cool
women in this country too,
but I've met a lot of them that were
like super nice and friendly and then you
go,
where are you from?
And they were like Canada and you're like,
oh,
okay.
Like you don't have any weird hangups.
I this a lot.
The weird,
the weird sex hang up.
It's like,
you know girls were in,
the guys are going to think they're slut.
Have you ever dated a girl?
Fucked her on the first day and then like
she was like your your girlfriend for
years.
Oh yeah.
Yeah,
me too all the time.
It's totally like the girl,
that girl think that that's
a bad thing to hold back.
No it's not.
I mean it's not wise.
Yeah,
definitely not wise.
Actually when they do do it,
I now think different about
it than I used to come out.
I'm like,
ah,
that was too easy,
but I'm not going to be like,
no,
I'm not dating you anymore.
When you were younger
especially,
it's so hard to find someone
that you really enjoy.
It's hard.
Like you're looking for pretty and you
look at for what you're attracted to and
then once you get to them,
well it's sort of like
you start reading a book,
you know,
and you don't know what the hell the
stories about until you get into the book.
And so you meet him and you go,
wow,
she's pretty.
And she talks and you know,
we're talking to each other and you know,
you'd like to get her naked and like get,
you know,
you bet.
But once you start finding
out what the story is like,
oh,
okay,
I don't like the story.
I got to go you fucking piece of shit.
And then you have to try to
find one that you actually do,
like a story that you like and the idea
that you can meet someone and right away
know that you liked that story.
Sometimes you do,
sometimes you meet someone and then
it's fucking awesome from the moment you
meet him,
you're like love being around them
and you never have any problems,
but for the most part that doesn't happen.
Right.
Especially if you're a fucking idiot.
Right,
right.
We all know that one dude at least
who will never have a relationship.
He's just unfuckable.
He just,
he just can't keep it together.
Can never get a girlfriend.
Like it'll have one fuck it up and
I'll have another in fucking right.
Yeah.
We all know that one dude who
just never has a girlfriend,
just can't keep it together.
Yeah.
I'm trying not to have the
more older I'm getting the,
I'm trying more and more
not to have girlfriends,
even though I don't like being alone.
But I also,
I also,
it seems like my mind's just check I'm
in a place right now where I'm trying to
do a lot of stuff,
you know what I mean?
Instead of where back
in like 10 years ago,
I'm more like,
I just like couches and watching TV,
doing a lot of stuff.
I mean,
you still go out.
Yeah,
a lot too.
But you're,
you've got a lot of podcasts,
a lot of projects,
art projects,
all these different things you're doing
and like the cat shirts and just doing
comedy's biggest thing,
all of it taken out the comedy clubs.
Well that's another issue too because,
uh,
if you have a girl and
you're dating her and you,
you're out almost every
night doing comedy,
right.
They're going to get annoyed at you,
man.
Yeah.
I've had,
I've had girls that I was dating and got
annoyed at me being a comedian and none
of them want to just hang
out at a comedy club.
Well,
some of them don't mind
for a little while.
They don't mind,
but after awhile it's
like God damn it dude.
I can't hear you tell the same
fucking jokes three nights in a row.
Right?
Like can we go do something?
I can't.
I got to work on my set.
Oh God.
You know,
girls got a job,
she works all day.
And then after work you guys are supposed
to get together and you got to go do
it set and
yeah.
Then Nate,
Kate dating someone.
That's a comic though.
That's
highly unrecommended as well.
Right?
That's one of the hardest
things in life man.
It's finding someone who compliments you.
Like what?
I mean,
not like says you look so good.
But I mean like someone who you're there
style of being a person and your style
of being a person like mesh up.
Well it's very difficult to find.
She's in wine cause I think about
that sometimes like you know,
we unlikely couples that we know.
You know,
we knew,
we know so many couples were like,
you know,
yeah.
I guess somehow or another
that shit works like that.
His thing.
And her thing together.
Like I wouldn't want to be with her and
if I was a girl would want to be with
him,
but together they figure it out.
Yeah.
There's some weird couples that I like.
I think the best couple,
I know it's time to grow.
I was going to say that too,
that they seem like they were
designed for each other there.
I think there's like the kind of couple
of where you're going to find out that
they're related in a couple of years.
There's something to it that it's like,
this seems a little too perfect.
They're so friendly to each other.
It's so nice.
But if you stop and think about it,
if any one of our friends,
not Ari,
he would get grumpy.
You wouldn't want him to be a girl.
No ducking.
Wouldn't mind.
But he might snap at you too.
Yeah.
If he takes off some of our best friends
and turn their personality into to uh,
make them a female,
you would be the best way.
The best girlfriend you
want to fucking slap.
You would be a dirty bitch that
I could let my friends fuck.
That's,
you'd be,
I could bring my friends over.
They would fuck you.
It'd be like whatever.
I like sex.
Whew.
Yeah.
I don't think I've ever dated a sexist.
I've never been successful
dating another comedian ever.
I dated one during the open mic days.
I dated this girl but didn't work out.
It would be in your head.
It seems like it would be the best one.
I've did it a few comics,
but it's always was fun
like running material
by them because they're,
you know,
them helping you.
That was really cool.
I think it would be,
but the downfall is like
if you break up with them,
they're in your fucking sandbox
with you for the rest of it.
You know,
like I was already situation with Esther.
I still have to fucking
see Esther like every,
I mean I love seeing Esther Esther now,
but for a while.
And Tony,
you know what's weird
with Tony Hinchcliffe is,
is that Tony dated her for like
a year and a half before you,
before right before me.
Oh my,
I didn't know Tony and so then
when I met Esther I had no idea.
Did you ever fuck her and go to Tony?
Fuck you like this?
No,
no.
Influx or like I like the way you do.
Do you spit in her mouth?
Barry crazy to go.
Do you go 50 shades of gray on her?
Fuck yeah.
No,
excuse me.
She'll,
she's pretty intensive bed but
no like thing were about it was,
is that I then met Tony after
we started dating because I the,
I had to like he,
Tony was like calling her still and doing
that kind of shit where like it would
be four in the morning be like,
who's gone?
You'd be like,
Oh shit,
Tony,
who's that Tony Guy?
So then the one of the
first Brodie podcasts I did,
Brody experiment number one,
I think I invited Tony to be on the,
on the show.
Didn't even know the guy like,
like with Benji,
just to kind of make it so like
right now we know each other
cause yeah.
That's how I knew Tonia now so that you
could talk to him and tell him not call
asteroid.
Well there was a lot of things going on.
One was that,
that,
that he was like doing that too.
It was kind of like,
look,
I don't want some angry guy
getting pissed off at me,
you know,
that's a comic.
I was trying to be like,
hey,
this is me.
Nice to meet you.
Oh yes,
I'm dating Esther now.
Hey,
welcome.
You know,
you can't fuck her anymore.
Right.
But it was weird that now we're like,
me and Tony are like great
friends and he's awesome.
He's a good guy.
Yeah.
He did a Indianapolis with me.
He killed two.
Yeah,
it was,
um,
it was really fun.
He's a good dude.
Like,
look,
I said several times on the podcast,
one of the things that I really
love is seeing the new guys come up.
So fun.
It's like,
I love that there's pretty much a
never ending supply of standup comedy.
It's like you're always
going to have more people.
There's always going to be new ones coming
up is always going to be people that
are getting better.
It's just,
it never ends.
Luckily.
I think the clubs need to
have more open mikes though,
man.
I think that's a real issue.
I stand up Comedians
icehouse needs one for sure.
Yeah.
But um,
it's a real issue to have a
developing class of upcoming guys.
Like there's only a few clubs that
develop people from the ground up.
The laugh factory.
Good luck.
You've got to wait in line on Tuesday.
You got to get there at
9:00 AM and sign up shit.
And then they put your material on
youtube without telling you fucking,
I was like,
thanks.
What the fuck?
Well,
it's a good place to work out.
He doesn't put my shit up there.
Yeah,
of course.
But it's because I told them not to.
They were going to,
you know,
he wanted to and I said,
you can't.
No,
no filming me know,
but don't put it on the air.
Come on man.
I know somebody that was like,
look dude,
that's not cool.
Put Take my material.
Yeah.
They took it down and then the
following week they put it back up.
I'm not surprised.
Yeah.
They probably make you sign some shit.
Did you go to the Improv last night?
No.
What was it?
No,
it's the last night
that that bar was open.
That what bar?
That bar in the front there.
They're tearing all that
down and making it a steak.
Steak House or something?
Yeah,
they have a new bar that's in
the back of the club I guess,
and I've extended it and they tore down
the stage two and it's going to be a
weird decision making there though.
So whoa.
What?
What they're doing?
Well,
maybe they feel like they could
do good money as a steakhouse.
They actually have really good food there.
I was going to be the same kitchen.
No,
I think,
I think there's,
it's either that they're
franchising a place out,
which is what I heard originally,
but then last night I heard a steak house,
so maybe they're just trying to like,
hey,
let's,
I would like,
I would eat there every
day if it was a steakhouse
Fleming's or something like that.
Like open the front to a steakhouse.
Right.
That's a bad ass idea.
You know?
That's a great move though to have a
nice restaurant right next to a comedy
club.
We can come in and say
there's a nine o'clock show,
you go in at seven,
have a nice meal and then go
right over and watch a show
or just having a good kitchen.
And you know,
like some of these comedy clubs are just
like fried everything or that you look
at the Ice House,
they actually have like
chefs there that are like,
oh no,
this is actually
right dude from the ice house.
It was fucking jam.
It was really good.
It was good.
Yeah.
The ice house is bad ass.
It's,
you know,
there,
there's only like me,
I mean,
how many clubs are there in southern
California have good food that,
uh,
are also comedy clubs,
flags,
sounds flappers has great food.
Um,
the Improv,
almost all of them have good food.
They all have good food.
They all have like a decent
meg at the very least decent.
Right.
You know,
that's such a great idea.
Like I don't,
I'm obviously not,
not a non comedian,
but if I was a non comedian and that
was a job where I can have a meal and go
somewhere and go see a comedy show,
fuck what an awesome night.
You know,
especially if like you can go see someone.
That's good.
Yeah.
We were having this conversation
about how many standup comedians are,
are and uh,
think it was,
maybe it was me and [inaudible]
me and some other comic.
We're trying to figure it out.
And we started out by saying
this probably like all together,
like maybe 2000 in the whole country
that are professional comedians.
Let that go on the road and everything.
Yeah,
yeah.
Thinking about 2000,
I would say 2000.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a good note.
I mean,
there was a live open micros,
but you can't count those.
But if you're talking about even the
smaller guys that are still going on the
road playing a couple of clubs
are doing a couple of things,
2000 unless you count like maybe like
some guys that do like the college
circuit,
which they're only playing
bars and college areas you
and like not real comics,
but they sell themselves
as comics or something.
You know?
I bet there's like this whole group of
comics that aren't in the comic knee
circle at all that goes though,
right?
Yeah,
I guess so.
They just don't hang out with us.
Right.
I mean,
at a certain point in time,
you know,
a lot of comics become,
they just become like
theater actually like,
okay,
here's a perfect example.
Brian Regan,
hilarious guy,
brilliant comedian.
When was the last time you saw Brian
Regan come to a comedy club and fuck
around?
You know?
Yeah,
no,
we never see him,
but he does these big theaters.
He sells out theaters.
And so I think he just
does all of his writing.
Uh,
and knows what's funny and what's not
and just works it into his act as you
know,
as he doesn't mean these
theaters I was talking to,
we had Jim Florentine on
a podcast the other day.
He's a great guy.
I'm going to be working with him tonight.
Awesome.
Uh,
and he,
uh,
he was talking about how uh,
what's,
what's the guy from uh,
east coast that a really
funny comic comic,
but he doesn't like to fly.
So he doesn't do any west coast
shows that we talked about it model?
No,
no.
Uh,
the one that might be a works Mike be a,
yeah,
they might be DePaul like DePaul.
He doesn't like to fly.
I guess Nick Depalo doesn't go
like he did go past Chicago.
He doesn't fly past Chicago's,
he only does clubs on
that side of Chicago.
And uh,
cause I was like,
why don't I ever see nick
the Po like him anywhere.
I never see him anywhere,
but just because I don't live
on that side of Chicago anyway.
So,
but uh,
that's somebody I would like to see,
you know,
like start touring around.
He should also do a fucking podcast
cause Nigga nick did a radio show with
already lang and does he do a podcast now?
I think he's still does nick?
Look Nick should never
be on regular radio.
I mean he should be a
guest on regular radio.
Like you know if he has to do
Howard stern or something like that,
absolutely do it.
But Nick is a guy who you want completely
uncensored and the fact that he was
doing that Artie Lange show,
I would watch it sometimes on direct TV.
I was like I,
I know he has to hold back
here like he shouldn't,
he has to be in an environment
where there's zero holding back.
You know,
just let them,
let them rant and let him say what he
wants whenever he wants to said he's
hilarious.
He is like really right wing
beliefs about a lot of shit that I,
you know,
some of it I don't even agree with but
I think it's fucking funny as hell.
But you're never going to get
those on a regular radio show.
You just not going to these like some,
some guys get stuck in a situation where
the very thing that makes them awesome
is the thing they can't do when,
when they're on the job,
you know,
like being offensive,
saying ridiculous shit,
swearing and being real
sexual or whatever it is.
It's funny that you're talking about
you can't do that if you're on a regular
radio show,
you literally can't do it.
You know,
like you're so limited.
Like the,
like the way they would
to describe things,
I would watch them like dance
around bad words and shit.
I was like,
God,
this is so pathetic.
It's like a slave gig.
It's like you're,
you're,
you're censoring yourself.
You,
you're,
you're talking,
you're ad libbing.
But you know,
you can't say this and know.
You can't say that there's rules,
there's rules to this gig.
I'm a,
I'm on the radio talking,
but I can't be me.
Right.
I can't fully be me.
Can't use all my words because if I do,
everyone's going to get so sad.
He's gonna make certain
sounds with his mouth.
They're going to really piss people off.
And it's weird thing because it's not,
it's an intense thing because you can
say a word that means exactly the same
thing.
Like you can say,
apparently a woman was arrested because
she was having sex with men and then
while she,
uh,
let them put her penis inside her vagina,
she would start biting their face.
You could say that,
but you couldn't say this crazy bitch.
What she did do,
she would fuck these guys in the moment.
They stuck their cock in her.
She would bite down on their face.
You couldn't say that,
but that's the right way to say it.
You know?
I mean you could say having sex with,
but what if you wanted to
say stuck your cock in her.
You should be able to say that too.
Like it's the same goddamn thing.
You have the same image in your mind.
Exactly.
But one of them can
get you thrown in jail.
One of them get you like a
quarter million dollar fine.
Not only that,
you could say that word.
You got to say it in a different way.
Like you could say cock a doodle Doo and
you can say it on the radio and no one
could say a goddamn thing.
You could say pussy cat and no
one could say a God damn thing.
You could have a nice little pause in
there pussy cat and no one could do
anything.
It's nothing you did wrong.
You can't go to jail.
We are apes.
We are so fucking stupid.
As a culture like that is one of the
dumbest fucking things about people today.
The bad word thing,
it's unbelievable that
that's still around.
I mean,
and it's,
it's so ridiculous that it's one of
those things that because it's around it
because it's so silly and
we all have to follow it.
It makes us more prone to
following ridiculous rules.
It makes us easier to govern I think.
I think it makes us easier to control
because if you can get people to not swear
all day at work,
you're going to the,
you know,
on the job,
I don't swim.
I'd say sort of why the coffee or the
truck up a bumper on that fucking broad.
He don't,
he might say something like that while
you're going get a cup of coffee in the
kitchen,
but it'd be completely inappropriate.
And it's limited to dark,
shadowy areas when no one's around.
But the fact that you
don't do it every day,
all the day,
you can't always be free with your,
the way you communicate,
you're trying to portray
something at work.
You want to have a professional image.
You can't use those words.
I'm more likely to buy a car
or something from a guy swears,
you know,
if I think I can hang out with them,
he's like,
he's gonna talk to yeah,
some fucking Weirdo and wants to tell
me about the various features and can't
even throw a shit or a fucking
there.
Come on now.
Yeah.
I would always say [inaudible]
it gets fucking cold.
That's what I'm talking about,
man.
Some places it's a little weird.
I got this guy at cvs,
I was buying beer and uh,
it was Miller high life and it was
like people behind me and stuff.
And he goes,
dude,
I've always been saying when that'd be
cool if they actually had weed in this
beer.
And I'm like,
dude,
you're,
you work at CVS,
please don't talk like this.
And like it was really uncomfortable.
I'm like,
I just wanted to like cvs or not.
So I would like you to be professional
right now and not address me as if you're
a normal person because this is where I
buy medicine and I want you to be like
that.
I know I'm buying my Miller high
life medicine Miller high life.
That's not a good taste beer.
No,
it's a great beer.
It's the champagne when you're on drugs.
Ever had more high life.
I you don't want to
listen to the other day,
the Roth Show,
David Lee Roth,
our good friend,
by the way.
Yeah,
we're allowed to say that.
We talked to him for
fucking hours with them.
David Lee Ross,
the coolest man on earth.
We've actually in total to talk to that
guy almost probably like five hours
because that,
well,
the comedy store tonight was even
weirder because we weren't filming.
He was just hanging out.
But that's how cool he is.
But you weren't filming
and have it all on tape.
But I'm saying we didn't have a camera.
You know,
we didn't have like some gigantic set
up like this where he knew he was on a
podcast,
but I was watching his podcast,
the bra show,
which is pretty fucking funny man.
First of all,
he does it all in overalls
like he does his podcast.
And overall he wore overalls
on this in here too.
And he did the podcast fell he
wears now what do you eat it?
Where do you buy two of us.
And you're eating?
What are you doing?
I'm trying to eat my breakfast.
I'm getting trail mix.
Trail mix.
Um,
but he was talking about beers and
a that he loves like Budweiser.
He likes it.
Tasted Budweiser because
when he drinks like these,
like organic beers or micro
brews or what have you,
you,
he said you're missing a
little bit of a nuclear waste.
You're missing a little bit.
So there's a chemical taste.
It's just missing from that.
Well,
it tastes like what you,
you grew up thinking
beer tastes like a beer.
Had like growing up there was just
light beer and beer for the most part.
There wasn't that much
fancy stuff going on.
Fucking
stuff that I have here that um,
what is it Jamie black Butte porter.
Who makes that shit?
Do you remember?
Some,
some micro brew,
some Small Cup.
It's the best taste in beer
I've ever had in my life.
It's delicious.
It's a,
it's like chocolate.
I mean like it's so good.
It's like that but better.
It tastes better.
It's like,
it's like a lighter Guinness
but it's like Guinness.
But I had it,
I had a steak one night
and I have that shit.
I was like,
this is the best beer I've ever done.
I've never had a beer that's so tasty.
It was,
it's incredible.
And I didn't think anything of all
those micro brews before that day before
though,
that day I just didn't,
I didn't think,
I'm like,
it's beer,
it's beer.
I like beer.
But I like Heineken.
Heineken's delicious to me.
If I'm,
if I'm eating something and I
can get a nice cold Heineken,
I think Heineken tastes fucking great,
but I didn't think that like a
micro would be a totally different
sort of experience.
But some of them are,
man,
there's some bad ass mother fuckers
out there and making some crazy beer.
My friend Shane is just one like Columbia,
the won first place in this
big beer thing and now this,
now this local bar is serving his beer
all year because he won first place.
Holy Shit.
Chains of beer mogul.
Yeah,
he's been,
he started in his basement.
He's been doing it for
awhile and then he has like,
he built his own bar in his basement
with all has his own beers in it.
Yeah.
That's hilarious.
Cool.
Can you get him to sell us on?
Well he sell us some beer.
Oh sure.
Can you ship it?
Sure.
He can bottle it and everything.
He does the whole deal.
Yeah.
Dude,
let's get a tap.
Let's get a keg here with Shane's beer.
Can he make a keg?
Probably.
How does it mean how's he ship it?
Because you don't know.
How does he sell it to them?
I would have to ask
him if he's even do it.
The reason why I'm saying it's like he's,
if he's selling it to restaurants,
he must be right.
Giving them a CAG or
sorry if they're on it.
If I see the,
what's that bar in Columbus like brew
Brewery Barney [inaudible] parties.
But uh,
the one that right there on high street,
uh,
there's a,
there's a brewery that it's,
it's,
they're selling it.
So they might be actually
brewing it at the bars.
Like,
Shit,
I wish I knew the name of it.
Huh?
Oh,
so it's one of those places where they're
making it in the establishment and
then chilling it right there.
So there's no travel at all.
Oh No,
no.
Barley's barley's brewing company.
I think it's wearing it.
That's a real popular thing now.
And I swear to God,
until I had this black Butte porter,
whatever the hell,
and I promise you probably should
fucking say the name of it for these guys
because it's so God damn delicious.
Let me find it.
It's in my Instagram bitch.
Yeah.
Here's a,
here's actually Shane winning.
Uh,
here's the photos aren't barley's company
and as Shane and his friend and uh,
yeah.
Anyways.
What is the name of his,
his beer?
Uh,
let me try to find it.
Yeah,
I'll find it.
Labor guys.
I can't quit Instagram now.
Oh,
hi.
Optic nerve.
I,
yeah,
that's a great,
great name.
Yeah.
I can't quit Instagram,
but uh,
sometimes I do wonder
what the hell I'm doing.
Oh.
And their,
their tap is a big eyeball.
It's a big eyeball.
Yeah.
You know,
like the things that they pour,
like they hold down on it
and it's just a big eyeball.
Okay.
Just as black Butte porter,
Cath.
Dammit.
Yeah.
I,
I'm a,
I'm more of a fan of Jack Daniel's lately,
which is a horrible thing
because I just got into Jack.
I was like the last year of my life,
I've never been in a Jack Daniels and,
but now I just only liked to drink jack
and I don't even like drinking beer
anymore,
but I'm trying to force myself to go back.
Right.
This is,
this is the beer.
It's Deschutes brewery,
d,
s c h,
u t e s brewery,
and there's a on my Instagram,
here's a photo of one,
a glass of it,
the first time I ever had it.
So apparently now I know that there are
a lot of really interesting beers out
there.
And so now,
because I went to another place that
had one of those like local beers on tap
and Austin and um,
I've done,
I've done that a couple times,
a couple of different places and had like,
uh,
some,
some of the local stuff and some
of it's good and some of it's okay,
but this stuff is pretty fucking bad eyes.
I think there's a bunch of different
people doing a bunch of different things
when it comes to beer.
No,
I agree.
I can't tell if I like Ip.
There's a place by my house
called Tony's starts away,
which isn't even a dark place and they
just only sell IP address and it's just
all this handmade beer from California.
And there's like,
I dunno,
like a hundred different beers and each
one is like the alcohol content and some
of them are like ridiculous,
like Lehigh,
like illegal,
you know.
But uh,
I,
I've tried all of them
and they're all okay.
But I don't think like as I just
a drinking every kind of day,
I'm not like,
that's how I drink.
I like light and easy to
drink and not Sam's drinks.
Miller lite.
Yeah,
I'm more,
I'm just like that.
I'm the same way.
I like Miller Light Miller high life.
I like no more of a Miller guy,
Texas folk friends.
Shit.
It's Kinda fucked up.
And one of the things I
was thinking about when,
when,
when I was in New York,
maybe really think about how strange it
is that California doesn't have a public
transportation system.
You know,
when I was in New York and I was watching
all these drunk people walk down the
street,
I was like,
yeah,
you know,
you could just get fucked up here and
just get in the subway or take a cab.
You know,
in California,
if you get fucked up,
you're driving fucked up
or someone's driving you,
right.
It's,
it's,
it's a weird thing that we don't
have a public transportation.
I mean,
we have figured it out.
We have buses and they
have like the subway,
but it's like,
not assignments.
Like I can actually go
from North Hollywood to Ho,
uh,
like to the Staples Center
and I've done it before,
but it's,
it's,
you know,
I have to like drive,
ride my bike or drive to the train
station and drop it off and then go
underneath.
But it's honestly,
I didn't freaked out about doing some
ways in Los Angeles Weirdo vagrants in
fucking an earthquake.
Yeah.
It's just like a big
fear of mine could the
people though than earth moving.
But yeah,
I mean it's something
to think about though.
The fucking,
the Bart in San Francisco
is the craziest one.
Yeah.
That's the one that's under
the ocean in the ocean.
Fuck that.
Yeah.
You know how I found out about that and
when we did fear factor there back in
the design and um,
I got a hold of some sort of pot Brownie
or a cookie or something like that.
It was,
it was whatever it was.
It was an edible and it was extra strong.
And I didn't realize how strong
it was until mid ride on the Bart.
I was,
my ears were popping and I was like,
why am I ears popping?
And uh,
my friend Matt said,
because we're under underwater and I go,
what?
Like I didn't realize what we were doing.
We were in Oakland and we had to take
a subway to the city to have to have
dinner,
this,
whatever the fuck you
want to call it.
I literally had no idea this
thing went under the ocean.
So for five minutes or
however long it takes to,
to make that trip from
Oakland to San Francisco,
I was shitting my pants.
I mean sweating,
wiping my hands on my pants,
holding onto that bar and like the,
the steel bar in the middle of the
fucking thing and wiping my hands in my
pants,
just shitting my pants going,
we're underwater.
All right now.
That's the dumbest thing
I've ever heard in my life.
That's how I felt when we
went to Japan at one point.
Cause I overthought it and I'm like,
we're all very ocean right now.
Like there's a lot of ocean.
Like we can go down and there's
no emergency landing right now.
You're better off on ocean then you
are making an emergency landing on the
ground where I saw this fucking thing
about colossal squid's a documentary
about,
have you ever seen colossal
colossal squid before?
Giant squids are called?
Yeah.
The cold colossals are giant.
The colossal is the biggest
one they've ever bigger than,
than giant squids does enough.
Yeah,
I think it's a diff
bigger than a giant squid.
And I,
I think like the biggest one,
I think it was it seven feet tall,
but they're like dissecting this colossal
squid in like the eyeball alone is the
size.
I think they said have a
bowling ball or something.
Oh my God.
There's a photograph of one that caught,
yeah,
the class was a squid exhibit.
Is the exhibit of them catching this way,
but check this like,
like right here,
this eyeball like,
uh,
dude,
they can be 12 to 14 meters long.
That's 46 feet long.
Cool.
That's fucking crazy.
Stop and think about how long 46 feet is.
I guess that though includes the tip of
their stupid little stringy things they
have hanging in a VM that doesn't,
that shouldn't count for body mass.
That's like their hair.
Oh my God.
Look at that time.
Is that real?
What the fuck dude?
Is that a cutter?
Is that where the,
uh,
the topic,
that's not a cut.
That's where the top is.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
That's its eyeball.
Is that real?
Do you know?
It's eyeball developed
independently of the human eyeball.
It's eyeball.
DEPA developed independently of the human
eyeball and strikingly works with the
same principles because
they deviated from our,
you know,
whatever.
Wherever life came from,
you know,
whatever primitive life that came from
the ocean that really resulted in all
mammal life on the planet.
It all started out as ocean
life at one point in time.
That was the first life before
there was life anywhere else.
And they were like related to mollusks.
They'll related to like slugs
and what's really like here,
the difference between of cost is getting
a giant squid is that clause to squids
have these like these pretty much calls
and these claws are on this circular
thing.
And when you see them like play with it,
they're like this and they just turn them
around like a record and they're like,
these things can rotate
360 and it's just like,
like they're on like
these rotating things.
Like if they could just spin,
really pull that picture up again.
So there's suction cups have closets,
there's Suction Cup has
clubs and this part,
yeah.
And this part right here,
it turns and three 60 degrees so
it can turn in three 60 degrees.
It's the craziest documentary.
It's on Netflix right now.
It's called the colossal squid,
I believe.
And,
uh,
it's a terrifying animals.
It's so scary.
What's so funny is that I was
really tired laying on the couch.
I'm like,
alright,
I need a movie to put me to sleep
because I have to wake up early.
I'm just going to put on some
nature movie about fish or squid.
It's this,
look at these things.
I know.
Pull up.
Pull that picture up.
That one's insane.
Oh my God.
They're like shark teeth.
Yeah.
They'll let you know what it's like.
It's like a giant cat claw
that's coming out of those two,
right.
A giant one though.
Well,
I told you that the,
uh,
the legend of the Crackin,
that's one of the things that they've,
um,
they've discovered.
Look at that fucking thing and
that spins three 60 degrees to,
oh my God.
It's like I'm this weird plate.
It's so weird.
That is so strange.
So it just hooks in no
matter where it goes.
Yeah.
They showed like animals that
have been attacked by it,
like sharks and stuff like that.
And the sharks just all torn up from
it because it just latches in and just
rips.
That's fucking insane.
Yeah,
the ocean is so scary.
Yeah.
So I put it in this video
to like go to bed too.
Cause I thought like,
you know like oh a squid.
It's quiet.
It's not gonna make any noise.
It's going to be quiet documentary.
And then the whole time I'm just hearing
all this shit like we are now taking
the eyeball out and I'm like,
oh,
this is the most fucked
up video I've ever seen.
One of the fucked up,
most fucked up videos.
Nature videos.
Yeah,
that,
that's a new thing.
They were like octopus ones
that were just suction cups.
I didn't know that.
They're,
they're really like claws.
No,
only if you chop one off.
Don't think grow right back.
I don't know.
I know that's the case with
the alligators with alligators.
He chopped their leg off and
throw them back in the water.
They just fucking heal up
and start growing a new foot.
Creepy cons.
That's kind of cool though.
It'd be nice if that happened with people.
Yeah.
Chop your hand off.
You just grow your hand back.
Shop her day off and wait
for a big winner grow back.
That's how it works.
If every time you chop your dick off,
it just grew back bigger or are you just,
yeah,
it was like uh,
a chance that would,
and you,
you got got all the way to like 10
inches and you're like not satisfied.
That's taking the tramadol.
It's like a six month wait and then the
next time it grows shorter and you're
like,
oh my God,
I fucked up.
I should have stuck with the 10 gaps.
Or while he cut it off so much you develop
scar tissue or on your nut sack you.
Dick Dick just doesn't
grow to full length.
If there was a time,
if there comes a time where we really
can engineer the size of various body
parts,
people are going to look so strange.
I guarantee you it's going happen.
I mean it's just
a matter of time before someone has
giant like those foam number one hands.
That's what their hands are actually life.
You know,
genetically modified people sort of like
how we have tomatoes that you can sit
on a truck in the hot sun for
a day and they don't go bad.
You know,
you get to transport them for weeks.
They don't go bad.
It's like the duck lips.
No,
no,
no.
Because that's fake cause shooting shit
into their lips and it looks stupid.
This is your,
you're going to be able to engineered
big giant plump Angelina Jolie Lips.
You're going to be able to just get those,
there's gonna come a point in time
where there will be no ugly people.
There'll be no unattractive people
because we will engineer what people look
like.
And it probably at first it'll just
be rich people with then it's gonna
eventually get to a point where it's,
it's not going to matter.
It's going to be cheap enough like a
cell phone where the majority of people
have it.
But then I think we're
probably be going to,
I think evolutionarily we're probably
going to like start wanting to fuck ugly.
People are like,
you know what,
I need a robust girl.
The fucking thick waste.
And a face that could take a punch.
You know,
we're,
we're gonna like we're gonna not
like this artificial attractive,
perfect symmetry.
I bet.
I bet our,
our genetics will come
to recognize that that's,
that this artificial symmetry is
probably not good for the genome,
for competition.
That it's like it's been hijacked so it
will like veer towards like ugly people
or thick people.
Are you like
friend Tony's sister?
Hey,
exactly.
Go Shark.
Have you seen go shark?
What's that?
Go Scott.
It's a Goblin Shark.
What is it?
I don't know.
It's pretty cool.
Check to a movie.
This is this real,
yeah,
come on.
Oh,
a Goblin shark.
Yeah.
Oh yes.
It's got like a mouth inside of it now.
It's a creepy fucking cunt.
What it is,
it looks like a skeleton.
Sharp shape.
Jesus Christ
to the ocean is so gross.
I mean,
it's so fascinating really,
because you might as
well be in outer space
base,
right?
It's actually probably
crazier than outer space.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Because that's scary.
What a fucking monster.
It's kind of like there's a monster inside
of a skin of a shark that's using the
skin.
Just like hide it looks like,
like a moray eel coming out of his mouth.
I wonder if that was the answer
operation for alien.
Yeah.
Looks like it.
Right.
Wow.
Look at that thing.
What's it biting?
I think it's just like the camera careers,
like equipment.
Like they're just trying to
get it to bite something.
Most of the sticking it in front of it.
Yeah.
Frees itself
original shape.
Oh,
it got stuck.
And the bit that pipe or
whatever the fuck that is.
You know what's really crazy about
the ocean is they don't
even know what's down there.
They kind of know.
But there's so much room
for discovering new species.
You know,
they,
they discover new species
on the land every day.
Like there's always like,
and they actually found a,
like really recently
within the last decade,
like a big animal in Vietnam
that they didn't know existed.
It was like some kind of an
antelope or something like that.
They just,
Vietnam was so dense and there was um,
I think it was like 10 years ago
they discovered this fucking thing.
I might've even less than that,
but we've,
you know,
there's people that have been
almost every section of the world,
or at least once,
you know,
been near these parts of the world.
And although there's
some crypto zoologist,
I believe there's a bunch
of species to be found.
It's probably a fairly limited number.
Put the ocean man,
we fully discovered,
I think they said that they've,
um,
they've explored 10% of the ocean.
Like so 90% of the ocean,
they don't know what the
fuck's going on down there.
They have like,
they have maps of the depth and they know
like how far down it goes and what the
contour of the earth
looks like down there.
And they know like the
topography of the bottom.
But I don't think they
know all this stuff.
Vcs Now they,
they find new species every year.
They find tons of underwater,
mostly underwater species.
You know,
there's of course a lot of insects like,
like uh,
there's like there's a Darwin's bark
spider that they just found two years ago,
which is crazy.
It looks like a look.
See here's a,
that's like a cyclops.
I'd spider on the list.
Is there a place that gives you,
like is there a website
that had like a new species?
You can track them down be kind of cool.
No,
but if you just,
usually if you to put in
like top 10 species of 2012
or [inaudible] there is its
species.
Asu.
Yeah.
National Institute for
species exploration.
It's a Arizona state and
they have all the top 10
new species of 2012 wow.
Interesting.
I remember that.
A squid,
we played that before that squid that
they found near one of those oil rigs.
Never seen before with crab legs.
Creepy fucking monsters.
Gigantic squid with crab legs,
crab legs and big
country Shark Tooth Dick.
Like things that it just wraps
around stuff and rips it apart.
No is,
yeah,
fuck that noise.
Indeed man.
It's fascinating though.
It,
then we're,
you know,
if we found that,
what's really interesting,
if we found that thing
walking around on Mars,
people would be shitting their pants.
Like I'll just fucking thing it's
got this clause and it's why,
I mean it would be the subject of every
science fiction movie that people went
there and it,
it uh,
they brought back a probe and apparently
it had seeds of this squid thing,
like a venom head crab.
You were saying one of those.
What is that?
It's like a,
what the fuck is that dude?
That's like a fist.
I know.
That is so creepy.
And that's on land.
Is that a spider?
Take a head crab dude.
That looks like something from,
from halflife.
Is that half life?
You fucking
Dick was actually,
I thought it was
at first I thought it was
a real but didn't actually,
it's anyways.
Yeah,
if you found a squid on the moon you'd
be shitting your pants or you would say
it's going to Italy and
make a movie about it.
I mean like just an elephant on the moon.
People be like,
what the fuck?
Like elephants didn't exist.
And they found elephant on the moon.
Who'd would be like the
most studied thing ever?
We would be going crazy.
But you know it's on
the ground where like,
yeah,
I seen that.
Not that interesting.
Went to the Santa Barbara
Zoo the other day.
Lucky.
Aw,
sad part.
Which I still haven't
been to that is there.
Yeah,
dude,
you got to go to Santa Barbara some day.
Let's have a like a field trip day.
Beautiful show at night there.
Yeah.
It's so nice down there.
First of all,
Santa Barbara is like the perfect weather.
People are less stressed out because
there's no traffic and they're like,
it's a noticeably more chill town.
A lot of people go to move there when
they give up on the Hollywood dream.
I think if,
even if it is he here,
but uh,
they have a zoo,
small zoo,
I can get around it pretty quick,
but they have fucking gorillas and a,
they have a,
um,
they call them a bachelor,
the like bachelor groups
that they hang out in.
And a,
they had this one gorilla and
it was his birthday there.
So they'd given him a cake
or something like that.
And you get up right
close to that thing in.
Do you like what a ridiculous creation
by nature this re don't callously
muscular giant little human thing.
Five foot four,
200 and fucking 98 which
products leave like 400 pounds?
I think it was 398 pounds.
Just the gigantically muscular thing
that eats broccoli just has giant fangs
just to keep you the fuck away.
Why he eats Broccoli.
The end to fight for pussy.
That's why it has giant fans and that's,
that's what it's for.
They don't kill anything.
You look at the mouth of a gorilla,
gorillas like fangs,
like,
let me Google gorilla phase real.
Uh,
you would swear that thing eats people.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Look at that fucking picture.
Yeah.
You imagine that's an 800 pound primate,
those giant silver backs.
Especially the ones in the wild.
I like those zoo bitches
eating birthday cake.
She ain't got nicked birthday.
Birthday in the Congo.
You fuckhead birthday know this is
one of my favorite pictures ever.
These two gorillas leaping at each other
in the middle of a firefight walls.
They didn't even know the gorillas
existed until like the early 19 hundreds
after Degas.
Yeah.
That's,
we think of gorilla is something
that we always known about.
But let me see.
Discover the mountain gorilla.
Yeah,
but they think it used
to be just like vikings.
There's one.
It was just a,
I think it was just a,
it was a rumor.
I don't think it was a real animal.
I think people hadn't
been to the area where it,
uh,
it exists and so they,
um,
they just,
they didn't know man.
Yeah.
Okay.
1902 man.
Yeah,
it's a great discovery of the mountain
grill was 1902 now we think about that
with like,
that doesn't even make sense to us
that that's a hundred years ago.
111 years ago.
Is that just because maybe we didn't
have really good telephones at the time
that some people would like in
countries that had gorillas were like,
dude,
we're getting eaten alive
by these big gorilla mom.
Listen to this.
Nearly 2,500 years ago.
An expedition from the,
for Noah,
full neat Phoenician,
Phoenician merchant,
city of Cathartic to
western coast of Africa,
accidentally discovered a group of wild
gorillas upon first encountering the
gorillas.
African local shared their name
for the giant ape with them.
The rough translation of
which meant hairy person.
So this is 2000 it's 500 years ago.
These people wrote stories.
These are real assholes.
An expedition from Carthage road stories.
Some ancient explorers have described
gorillas as primitive Harry people.
They've also been referred to
as anthropoid or man like apes.
Wow.
This is nuts.
This guy spoke of,
I'm another guy in the
16th century spoke of them.
So it seems like what what,
what happens is these people
go and they see these things,
but it's so rare that like a westerner
ever went there that no one really had an
opportunity to study like 1902 it was
probably the first time like civilized
folk got on a big metal boat,
made it all the way the fuck down there.
You know?
Did they even have metal boats?
1902 they must've right?
Probably right.
They probably figured that shit out.
Those big giant metal
boats that they have now.
Like the titanic there,
that 1902 titanic,
right?
Well they're not.
The titanic was in the twenties no.
What year did the titanic go down?
How with and artist.
Wow,
1912 do you know how science fiction
that must have been in 1912 to see this
enormous like building
that floats on the water.
I wish we had better video of
the in Heidelberg or whatever.
It's didn't Annenberg.
Yeah.
That's not that big a deal though.
That's just a z.
A Zap one visual of that.
That,
I mean just the video that they
had of that was so intense.
Yeah,
pull that up.
All right,
so cool.
Hold that up.
The Hindenburg disaster.
Well that's when they realized
they couldn't do that anymore.
They thought they were going to be able
to like fly people all over the world.
Well this is going to be wonderful.
These giant gas balls,
but they didn't realize it.
When those things go down,
Holy Shit.
Do they go down hard?
They get hit by lightening and just
burst into flame in the middle of the sky
and everybody dies.
That was a strange time.
I told you that I have
a reoccurring dream.
I've had it several times and I,
I know I talked about it once before.
I had this weird crawling
and I wrote it down.
I wrote down the story
that happens in my dream,
but in my dream there was
a thousand Nikola Tesla's,
it wasn't just one guy,
it was like a thousand guys.
And the,
the thing that I wrote was actually
called like I wrote a piece called the
thousand Teslas and it was the 1940s is
the 1940s that I keep having this dream
this night in the 1950s rather like
during the era of those big Cadillacs,
it was big fucking things and the that
was still going on but they were flying
and that people were having
like these flying Cadillacs,
they were like that.
And there,
there was doc ports all over the city.
These platforms where you would pull
in with your giant flying Cadillac.
And it was a really strange
dream because New York City,
it was,
it was probably New York City
or wherever it was that was,
you know,
some large cities,
Chicago maybe.
But whatever the city was in,
which it took place was very much like
you would expect a city from the 1950s
but much more advanced technologically.
Like there was just some new
shit that we don't have yet.
And it was a lot of blimps flying back
and forth in the sky and there was a lot
of air travel.
It's like people kind of
completely abandoned traveling
with cars on the ground
or you know,
gotten rid of most of it in my dream.
It's a really weird fucking dream
I've had a couple times to do,
you know,
just to take place in la
or is it like he'll say,
oh no,
it doesn't.
It does.
It's all takes place in manmade creation.
So it's impossible to say where it's
taking place in the stupid dream of mine,
but were like walking out and watch it.
I'm an observer and the observer
and the dream is always like,
the concept is that there
was a thousand Teslas.
It wasn't just one super genius invention
guy that figures out it's just back to
the future.
What does this,
yeah,
it's not,
it's,
it's what it,
what it is like in my dream was like,
um,
it was,
what was that movie?
The rocketeer what was
that mother rocketeer yeah,
you remember that movie?
How like,
Oh shit,
she wasn't really high.
It was don't say that or I brushed her,
don't say that.
Um,
they,
uh,
they did a good job of that
movie of capturing that era,
the rocket tiers era,
but also having this crazy technology,
which was like,
if you look at those science
fiction magazines of the day,
that was the one thing that they sort of,
that's how they did it.
Like rockets and like,
like,
like new ideas and jet packs and stuff.
They all like looked
like they belonged in that time.
They all,
they didn't have the,
the sleekness of a Cadillac STSV you know,
they had that weird sorta
a rounded bulbous look of,
uh,
the,
the 1950s era or rocket man
was even earlier than that.
Right?
Yeah.
Look at that thing.
What happened to make it crash?
It just crashed or did there was,
are fired that started or as,
good question.
I didn't remember anything.
I think it caught on fire when it
was in the air and then it crashed.
Does it say,
well,
three hours the dirigible,
the dirge doubles.
That sounds like somebody
doing your underwear.
You Dick Leaks.
Like I got a dirge of Belem
in front of my underwear.
Dude,
I can't,
I got to come out naked.
Cause if she sees my underwear,
especially if you have white underwear,
you're taking chances.
Dubai's white dudes who
buy white underwear,
stop it.
Okay.
The front of your Dick,
you're pissed.
Flap is always going to be leaking.
You don't do that good
job of wiping your ass.
She walking around with white underwear.
You're a silly person
that said,
really should take
better care of your ass.
You know?
And maybe,
maybe if he just,
if everybody had those
Japanese toilets in it,
every place we went to,
I went to way
video game thing the other day too.
Um,
uh,
this company to they're doing for my new
show and like were there put me inside
of a virtual reality situation.
Oh cool.
It's pretty bad ass.
But when I went there,
they had one of those Japanese toilets.
It cleans your asshole.
No blow suppose fog on you.
Somebody posted this one that they haven't
Chicago and the airports now where it
has like Saran wrap that
every time you flush it,
it flips around like this protective
layer that goes over the toilet seat with
like a Saran wrap type thing.
So you always have like a fresh thing.
That's nice.
All right.
Half a minute.
Now if they can only figure out
how to do that on airplanes,
there's those,
the stanky as Dank is fucking toilets.
You ever shit in?
Oh there it goes.
Look at it.
Oh my God.
Just inflame.
People running screaming.
Oh my God.
Look at that thing.
Bland flames.
Oh my God.
Look at those people running out of the
bottom of it.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Oh,
you watched people burned
to death in this thing?
I didn't know that.
Holy Fuck,
man.
You can see people moving in
the fire trying to get out.
Oh my God.
That is insane.
Ooh.
You know that's the first time
I've ever seen that in full.
Yeah,
it's,
it's pretty.
There's a,
I think even a better version of that.
That might be the only one,
but maybe I saw a fake one.
Holy Fuck.
I swear there was a difference.
Why don't you people die?
Even people that died a long ass time ago
when you know you're watching them got
die.
That's not fun.
The creeps me out.
Yeah.
Especially that way those people cooked.
That was a weird ball of fire too,
man.
That was enormous.
That's like a building
that's made a fire and it's,
you know,
I mean it literally,
it was that big.
It was like,
like a giant skyscraper made a fire.
Yeah.
Whoops.
We don't do it that way anymore.
Hey,
you live,
you learn demand.
Got a crick,
crack a few eggs to make an omelet.
Alright,
you fucks things over.
We're going to bring the sucker home.
Uh,
Brian and I started out three years ago,
a fucking around at my
house on a laptop and,
uh,
now,
three years later it's become some strange
thing that's probably pretty much out
of our control now at this point.
It's Kinda got a life of its own.
Um,
and uh,
I,
no one thought it was coming and neither
Brian nor I planned on it being wheat.
I never would have thought we'd had a
studio or never would have thought it'd be
almost a million people downloading some
of them in that sometimes more than a
million.
It's,
it's real weird and a,
this show a that we did this weekend at
the state theater sort of highlighted
that.
And uh,
man,
I tell you,
I don't even know.
I,
I don't even believe it's real sometimes.
It's very strange.
When Joey Diaz went on
stage at the state theater,
I swear to God,
I didn't even believe it was real.
I wish I'm kicking myself that I didn't
film it because he went on stage and
that place fucking corrupted it.
W it was like,
it was like Elvis came into
the building or something.
It was nuts,
man.
Joey Diaz in New Jersey and you know,
everybody knows he's from North Bergen.
They,
they went insane.
It was like,
there was so happy to see him.
It was a for real,
it was one of the most incredible
sets I've ever seen anybody have.
It was,
it was beautiful to watch just
watching him go out there.
What the fuck is going on?
We just appreciate the fuck out of it.
We never saw this coming and uh,
everybody keeps saying the same thing.
Uh,
Hey,
don't,
don't stop doing it.
Don't stop doing this.
We're not going to stop.
Don't worry.
We're not stopping.
And all the people that you say that,
you know,
that,
that tell us it changed their life
and that finally you have a positive
influence and we appreciate
the fuck out of that.
We never saw it coming,
but we appreciate the fuck out of it
and we take great responsibility for the
whole thing.
I'm the male Oprah.
Okay.
That's how we're doing it.
But not,
I mean cash wise,
I mean I'm trying to positive
but not always positive.
Sometimes I'm a little cunty.
Oh,
you have a delicious place.
Hey,
settle down.
So,
um,
thank you everybody.
Thanks for,
for everything and uh,
we're,
we're all a part of this fucking weird
thing and I know that sounds very
pretentious to say,
but that is the case.
You know,
there's,
there's no getting
around it at this point.
We can't really dance around in to call
and anything other than what it is.
It's a,
a very,
uh,
happy piece of circumstance and,
we enjoy it all.
And,
uh,
we,
appreciate the fuck out of all the people
that come out to these comedy shots
means the world to us.
If you want to go see Tony Hinchcliffe,
Brian Red Band and the lovely Sam Tripoli,
they will be in Sacramento this weekend,
Friday and Saturday at the punchline,
Sacramento.
And then the great cobb's
comedy club in San Francisco.
One of the best comedy
clubs on the planet Earth,
as is the fucking punchline.
They're both pretty fucking
jam in northern California,
filled with some of the coolest people
on Earth to northern California is where
it's at.
Pitches.
I have to go in and do your radio.
Remember that?
Yeah,
that's always a good time.
Uh,
hey.
Thanks folks.
Thanks for everything.
Winnipeg is basically sold out.
You fuck.
So is Vancouver.
So a,
you snooze you lose and uh,
we will see you tomorrow with
the Great Ari Shaffir and uh,
also tomorrow with,
um,
our pow Amy Schumer.
She's one of the other ones is successful
in relationship with the comic.
And we'll tell you that that
comic is tomorrow if you tune it.
And I wasn't.
Yeah,
there you go.
I let it out.
I don't,
I don't like fucking teasers.
I don't like spoilers.
I don't like cliffhangers.
But I like you.
You're Fox,
so thank you.
Thanks to Tang.
Go to rogan.ting.com
save yourself some money.
stamps.com code word,
J R e n on it.com Codeword Rogan Day.
You are day you be here we are.
We'll see you soon.
All right.
How to wrap that up.
Good.